e
good
morning um I'm glad most all of us were
able to make it in um uh some of us had
more snow than
others um but uh we have a busy few days
um this week um plus a house
session um and uh so um all our clocks
have different times but um mine says
9:30 so um we'll get started with our
first bill for the
day oh yes thank you with and before our
first bill of the day uh our new uh
standard operating procedure is the
Pledge and um representative Cornell
would you like to lead
us
Al the United States of America and to
the rep stand One
Nation indivisible withy and justice for
all thank you
everyone um our first bill is is HB
222 repealing the requirement for a
memor memorandum of understanding
between a chartered public school and a
school district regarding how students
with disabilities will receive special
education
services and um our own Committee Member
uh representative Balon uh is all set it
appears so uh please go
ahead uh thank you Mr chair and my
fellow members of the House Ed UC ation
policy and administration committee for
the record I'm Peggy balbon representing
the towns of Greenland Northampton and
Ry on the seos and I'm the prime sponsor
of HB
222 um again which would repeal the
requirement for a memorandum of
understanding between a chartered public
school and a school district regarding
how students with disabilities will
receive special service special
education
services I'm bringing forward this
legislation at the request of the New
Hampshire Association of special
education administrators and the New
Hampshire Alliance for public charter
schools these are the two groups
involved in producing and implementing
memorandums of understanding between
public charter schools and local
education
agencies briefly uh charter schools are
public schools but run independently
generally exempt from many state laws
that govern traditional Public Schools
technically Charter Schools as all
public schools are required to admit
students with disabilities per fedal law
unlike other states New Hampshire is
unique in that the school district in
which the student resides is responsible
for providing um uh free appropriate Ed
public education commonly known as a
fate um and that includes the
funding in including the funding and
required services to each child with a
disability including these children with
individual education plans that a parent
has independently enrolled in the
charter school to every child with a
disability there are four ways in which
this would
occur uh one is to uh send resident
School District staff to the Charter
School the second way is to contract
with the charter school for the Charter
School staff to provide the
services Third Way is to contract with a
vendor to provide services at or away
from the charter school and the fourth
um way you can do it is to provide
services in the Resident District's own
Public
Schools a student's IEP is developed by
the resident district and details What
specifically designated instruction and
related Services the student will
receive it is up to the local education
agencies and the charter schools to
determine how the services will be
delivered occasionally it can be a
challenge for school districts and
charter schools to come to an agreement
on all aspects of the IAP but for the
most part these barriers are resolved by
working
collaboratively once signed by the
parent the IE is the legal document that
commits the school district to provision
of services outlined in the I
AP it's important to note that in 2016
there was a legislative commission
formed that was charged with identifying
challenges related to special education
in New Hampshire's public charter
schools and bringing forward
recommendations to improve this process
ensuring that all students with I APS
are reserving the services that they
need uh one of these recommendations was
that uh the New Hampshire education
department require the leas and public
charter schools to formally detail how
students with IEPs will receive required
Services a law requiring M us was passed
in
2021 unfortunately rather than smooth
the path M us have created more work and
increased legal costs for both the
school districts and the charter
schools While most charter schools in
leas have been able to come to
agreements in completing the memorandums
of understanding many still remain
unsigned mind primarily due to financial
disagreements currently while M are
required by law there is no impass
resolution process so they're not
enforceable according to the Department
of Education there are currently 94 M us
that have not been signed for the 2024
25 school year and 16 of these were not
signed for two consecutive years in a
row since the LA since and Charter
School Personnel Personnel are spending
hours of time hammering out details and
incurring increased legal expenses they
are requesting the repeal of the
requirement both federal and state laws
require that school districts provide a
fape to all eligible students and data
from the Department of Education
supports that no school district has
refused to provide special education or
related services to any child attending
a public charter school
because the even because the memorandum
of understanding was not signed by both
parties so in other words if theou is
not signed uh students are still
receiving
Services uh prior to the requirement
there are three special education
complaints filed related to the
provision of services at a charter
school so far this year that number is
the same so it seems that the existence
of the m has had little effect I hope
that you will support this legislation
to remove theou requirement to allow
both the charter school personnel and
District special Educators to focus
focus on educating our students rather
than administrative tasks and I'm happy
to take any
questions thank you representative
questions from the
committee represent
Cornell Thank you for taking my question
um so you said that you brought this at
the request of both the special ed
administrators and the association of
charter schools so it seems they are in
agreement that this is the best way to
go
forward thank you for your question um
Yes actually um over the summer and um
in the fall I attended a a couple
conferences and meetings with with the
two groups and this is one of the um uh
barriers that is kind of is had really
gotten in the way of
of educating students um what they found
and I'm going to there I have some
wonderful support back me that can
actually refer to specific instances and
give you better examples that I could
thank
you any uh other
questions see none thank you very
much representative Mooney
thank you Mr chairman and good morning
to you and to members of the House
Education and policy and administration
committee for the record my name is
state representative Moren Mooney I
represent the town of marac that's
Hillsboro County District 12 I am here
in support of House Bill
222 an act repealing the requirement for
a memorandum of understanding between a
chartered public school and School
District regarding how students with
disabilities will receive special
education services I do have written
testimony however there's a delay in my
getting copies so I'll have to wait on
everyone getting a copy but that's forth
coming every now and again a piece of
legislation strikes me as well-meaning
but entirely and completely
impractical the requirement of a
memorandum of understanding also known
as a
mou comes from one of those pieces of
legislation and it must now be repealed
as a law when I first read the original
Bill where this mou came from which is
Senate Bill 238 in 202 2 to implement
anou for special education for Charter
Schools I just knew that this would be
double
duplicate extra and
unnecessary
work charter schools are already
required to meet work on and Implement
IEPs and 504s per federal and state law
as well as New Hampshire ad
administrative
rules special education is a highly
regulated and monitored area of the law
the process of determining special
education services takes time personnel
and financial resources and typically
works like
this and I will spell it out Public
Charter School Personnel extensively
meet in what's called team meetings with
parents Specialists and sending School
District officials to finalize special
education
services these meetings result in a
written document either an IEP or a
504 these binding documents already
include all that is listed in current
RSA 194 hyphen B Roman
8 which is what House Bill 222 is asking
to
repeal additionally there is model
documentation already on the nhdoe
website model documentation is also
required for this uhou
law then the students teachers and
guidance counselor must receive the
documents and become very familiar with
them to implement what is required for
the student these meetings are thorough
detailed labor intensive and time
consuming Additionally the documents are
continuously reviewed throughout the
year and follow-up meetings are constant
to ensure implementation is properly
occurring aou requirement serves
no no separate purpose to the required
relationship between public charter
schools and sending districts theou is
just an additional substantial layer of
duplicative work in a
fastpaced resourceful School environment
that will unnecessarily cost
administrators teachers and parents time
and
expense our legislature cannot do this
to our schools our role is to improve
processes not to bog them down I ask
that you recommend ought to pass on
House Bill 222 and I thank you for your
attention this morning thank you Mr
chair thank you representative um yes go
ahead thank you and thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative money for
taking my question um I did have a
question about I thought you had
mentioned um RSA 194 B8 as being the
section needing repealed I just wanted
to clarify
we were only talking about 194
b58 thank you for that question so the
repeal is 194 hyen B colon
5 Roman 8 okay great not just
195 194 B8 sorry thank you thank
you for the
questions uh I just had had one um as I
recall uh the M were uh put in place as
a means of trying to um have a
agreements put in place because of
problems um with uh charter schools and
Resident
districts um on where and how um and the
cost of providing uh
Services
um is it uh your position that um those
um issues uh can be resolved without
anou absolutely
yes thank you in fact I would go further
to say that an mou will complicate those
issues with now a document that could
potentially be conflicting with the
finalized IEP in 504 special education
directives thank you
uh seeing no further questions thank you
very much for your
testimony uh Jane
buron good morning good morning my name
is Jane B R bulu and I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire
Association of special education
administrators our organization is a
nonprofit
nonpartisan a professional organization
that supports leaders in the field of
special education I am here today
representing over 300 of our members and
we are in support of HB 222 I have
provided you with some written
documentation I also emailed it to you
uh for your reference so I won't go and
and read through my entire testimony but
I will just touch upon the highlights
the first thing that I'd like to mention
is that our association uh works
collaboratively with Charter Schools we
recognize the importance of charter
schools within New Hampshire and our
educational communities our organization
uh meets monthly with our Charter
Schools we have what we call a
collaborative work group we engage the
Department of Education in those work
groups uh the work groups are designed
for us to identify best practices and
build upon those and identify any
challenges and problem solve around them
um and we've been having this work group
for over two years now and meet on a
regular basis we've also designed um
some collaborative professional learning
opportunities together we have uh
co-sponsored with the Department of
Education and the alliance uh to uh
Charter School um conferences and we
will have another one um in in the
summer
um as already mentioned um as in idea
the IEP really is the legal binding
document that uh holds the district
accountable for everything that's in the
IEP theou is not uh legally required and
just adds another layer of paperwork uh
we have seen over the past two years um
that theou really has not had any
positive impact upon kids the The
Children and Youth that we serve serve
um their learning or the families um
that are engaged with um the children
with with IEPs as already mentioned in
2016 there was a legislative commission
formed to study uh special education and
charter schools there were many
recommendations brought forward in uh
that report the F the biggest one
centered around funding and when M us
are not being signed they typically are
around um disputes related to uh the
costs and fees uh related to special
education so funding still continues to
be um a significant issue um some of the
other bullets um that I have in in the
testimony um and again I'm not going to
go through all of them because some of
them have already been mentioned um but
this really has proven to be hours and
hours of time and legal fees both for
school districts um and our chartered
public school and we really feel as
though this time and effort should be
dedicated to the Children and Youth and
their families as well as um trying to
recruit people to work um in special ed
in our charter schools and our Public
Schools so if we could have that time
back and dedicate it more uh to have an
impact on on children and family we
would appreciate doing that um in
closing I would say that revoking this
uh requirement for anou would only
benefit all of us um it would uh give us
the opportunity for more time to work
with our Charter Schools um more time um
to recruit folks to work in our schools
um but it really hasn't been anything
that we would say is a benefit uh to any
of us so um thank you very much for your
consideration of Our Testimony and I
would be happy to answer any questions
that you might have thank you questions
representative
Woodcock thank you chairman good morning
good to see you again um and thank you
for your testimony as usual it's very
complete just a couple questions in in
context if I
recall a couple years back when this
first uh dialogue came about there was
the there was a problem regarding the
time frame particularly if I recall
correctly at the beginning of the year
that lag from when the youngsters came
in and the time the child school got up
and the public who it up and there's a
there's a time a gap there and I thought
that that Jan that this is one of the
intents of the all you would to try to
bring them back in a collegial way to
try to get those things worked up it
seems like what you're saying is we've
gone one step ahead and two steps
backwards thank you for the question and
to your point that is correct and you
know and we try to adjust the date of
when these were signed and and that
didn't help and you know we we don't
always know when kids enroll in in
charter schools this is a a parent
enrolling and especially with our kids
who are struggling um they don't often
times tell the charter school that my
student uh had an IEP and they don't
tell um the public school so it's really
no one's fault and and parents have the
right to disclose or not disclose um but
it it just we we do a lot of catchup and
by the time we realize that we've got a
struggling child um we then learn oh he
he did have an IEP so yeah we we do a
lot of catchup thank you thank you
sure sure any further
questions um just we had um just one
from me we had testimony earlier that
there were 95 94 unsigned um M us uh
currently I believe uh mainly due to
financial reasons um can you talk a
little bit about the financial reasons
that have been holding up M
us yes I you know um um and I and I
think our Charter Schools can also
reinforce this um when school districts
and our our charter schools are writing
up the M us some are writing up
contracts in addition to the saus if in
fact uh a charter school is providing
the services um they can determine what
the fee for service is um and charge the
school district that and and there have
been some disputes around Fe for
service um who's determining that um if
if the charter school is Contracting
with someone to do that um not allowing
or making available the contract um with
the independent organization to the Lea
as um evidence of what this service is
costing there have been disputes over
Individual Services and what to charge
versus small group group there have been
uh conflicts with differing prices with
differing districts not being consistent
um and again not this is not anyone's
fault but there are some
inconsistencies um and so sometimes that
that is the barrier does that help to
clarify thank you you're welcome maray
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I did have one small
question about how it would be the case
that the public charter school would not
be aware that a child has an IEP um
aren't those files something you receive
upon
enrollments this is a parent enrolling
um their child and they don't have to
disclose that information our charter
schools accept all kids um and the
parents don't necessarily have to um
disclose that
information repres wood thanks um F and
represent Celli's question if I may to
provide Clarity because um I want to be
sure I have this right which I probably
don't um is the China school do the
China school have the ability to
contract uh prior to the approval of the
Lea I mean can they go I thought I
thought um that the first priority was
the Lea trying to provide the services
but can the child school as a prior to
that just say no we have it right here
we're going to do it the and then that's
is that part of that conflict or don't
they have that right that several of the
charter schools and again our Charter
School colleagues can speak more to this
but several of our Charter Schools do
have staff um employed um some of them
can't fill those positions so they're
Contracting um you know we we just for
from our perspective we just want to get
the services for kids okay no matter
what we have to do if the if the charter
has to contract if we have to pay the
charter schools if we we have to
contract um first and foremost we want
to get the services for kids so it can
happen in a variety of different ways
okay okay thank you thanks chair you're
welcome see no further questions thank
you very much thank
you Beth meckler
good morning and thank you for if you
could press that the button there yeah
go okay thank you good morning and thank
you for accepting my testimony this
morning my name is Beth
McLure and I am a member of the board of
the alliance for public charter schools
I'm also a member of the
NHA the organization that um Jane is
executive director for and I am the
principal at strong foundation's charter
school and have been for um ever since
we opened our doors 17 and a half years
ago um I'm here to testify in favor of 8
House Bill 222 to repeal
Theus
um when the when the law was finalized
um I had resigned myself to doing doing
whatever it took to get Theus worked
through and signed I was not looking
forward to it and um I made the
assumption that the special Educators in
the state had needed this even though in
17 and a half years we did not need it
we were always able to work it out and
sign contracts with the districts if we
were providing in
Services when I joined the collaborative
work group with the New Hampshire
Association of special ed
administrators I was surprised to learn
that they too were very frustrated with
theou so we all agreed that we
would
request
um look for a sponsor for the bill to
um
repeal the mou
RSA I am
aware of no Charter
School whose
students well all charter school
students are receiving Services um for
the most part and any who are not it is
not due to to anou being unsigned so
there are no services not being provided
because there areus that weren't
signed we
have this year over 70 students in our
school with IEPs and that's a fairly
typical
number we work with over 15
districts and we as I said have always
been able to come to an agreement the
first year that Theus were required
during the summer I spent at least 80
hours working with our different school
districts reviewing Theus sending them
to our lawyer proposing alternative
language all while we were trying to get
the school open it was exhausting it's
not like I stopped doing the other
things I just had to stay up later to
try to get them all done we also spent
several thousand in legal fees that
year the second year which was this past
year I would estimate that we spent I
spent over 50
hours on this because some of our
districts just kept the
same as the previous year but I still
had to review all of them to see if
there were any changes from the previous
year and when there were or if there
were
discussions run the um changes by our
lawyer which again incurred legal fees
um
Theus have a there's a template for
theou that nhed developed um a lot of
the districts don't use it and so there
are different M out there as I said
earlier we have not needed to do this it
created conflict it created unnecessary
time spent in a very full schedule
working with children with iups I should
say too that
um I have been a special educator for 35
years and so I've got a lot of
experience with working through iups and
helping children um with disabilities
and only want the best for them so I
certainly would not testify in favor of
this repal if I felt like it would hurt
them thank you thank you
questions yes representative Cornell you
chair thank you for taking my question
how many districts did you say you dealt
with for year over 15 and you have no
problems with special ed services with
any of those districts no we've always
there have been bumps in the road
sometimes but we've always been able to
work them out thank you president
Woodcock thank CH good morning thank you
for testifying when um there's an impass
or the mou isn't working working and I'm
thinking more of your collaborative
group that you work with I'm sure you
have other information does doe ever
step in and help out with uh impath or
intervene to give you assistance on
these or you just sort of left between
you and the school district it's just
between the charter school and the
school district okay thank
you see no further questions thank you
very much for being
here Rebecca fet from the Department
good morning thank you chairman cordelli
and the committee um I just wanted to
speak briefly about the
bill excuse me the department proposed
theou for charter schools in the 2022
legislative session as there was no
oversight for the provision of special
education within charter schools at the
time it was reported To Us by both
charter schools and districts that they
had students that at times were not
getting their services on time as the
two entities could not come to an
agreement about how the student was
going to receive Services we worked with
both charter schools and districts to
develop the mou based on the concerns
expressed before the legislation and
from that work group with the input of
the commissioner we put forth the
current template for the mou since the
implementation of the mou we have heard
that it is cumbersome and difficult to
do one or both parties are unclear on
how they should be using theou as well
as concerns with there being no support
if one party or both parties are not
willing to develop anou this then leads
to the
concerns that there is no recourse for
either party if they cannot come to an
agreement we also have had concerns
regarding the fees charged to schools
for services and there is no
documentation to support the changes to
districts and several districts are
charged full price for a service when it
could actually be split between several
districts
while we understand the concerns with
theou we would express our concerns with
going back to no oversight of special
education in charter schools they do not
have approved programs as traditional
Public Schools publicy or the JMA and
the private providers are required to
have they are only considered a regular
education environment yet many of them
have special education teachers and
provide services without an approval
from the Department there is no process
to support Charters and districts if
there is disagreement regarding the
provision of special education services
and there are no guidelines as to how
Services contracted by charter school
should be paid by the districts as you
consider this legislation to Mo remove
theou we ask that you consider any or
all of the items listed above about the
oversight of special education in
charter schools I'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much uh
questions represent
Woodcock good morning I see you every
day here I should just move in um thank
you for coming in I uh as you said I
think in your context in your dialogue I
didn't read that I was listening to you
it's exactly that um the department
initiated the the idea yes uh of the m
to try to help the uh difficulty with
the transition and oversight
yep so if if I'm wrong stop here so I'm
thinking as we've heard other testimony
that it hasn't worked and that was sort
of became more of an obstacle than an
assistance I guess my question is during
that you and I'm thinking I'm hearing
you say it's it should still be
maintained you didn't say you support it
but you didn't say you didn't take a
position of it it seemed that you
thought there still was a need for that
type of oversight but my question is if
you if over the last two years we saw
all these problems or the school
districts and leas and the child who saw
all this obviously they must have
because there's a bill here they're
talking about it did did your department
ever step in and help out so we have
tried to help out with as much Authority
that we have but we can't order either
of them to do something there's no um
there's no provision within the law for
us to say You must do or you have to do
or you so that so we did help as much as
we could but we don't have any re
there's no recourse if they can't come
to an agreement there's no um appeal
process there's nobody I can send them
to um so so that was part of the issue
was that there we don't have any
authority to do that okay so and and I'm
not and we're not opposed or supporting
my concern is that if we take this away
then there's nothing that would that
would help us with special education in
the charter schools I know that it's a
it's a problem I know that it's
cumbersome I know that it takes a lot of
time but this is this is all we have so
thank you thank you
yes representative welcome uh back to
education again thank you Mr education
policy I should say right we live and
breathe education yes thank you for
taking my question excuse
me
so the first part is does the current
special education audit include auditing
charter school special education
services no because there's no we have
no authority to monitor Charter Schools
or go into charter schools so there's
there's nothing um that we do with
Charter Schools currently besides
theou followup or second question really
yeah given what you said a moment ago in
response to representative
Woodcock does the department have
recommendations of other ways
to address the concern of challenges
between Charters and school districts
since the consensus both here so far and
online is in support of removing theou
is there something that would be better
I think that that's uh a conversation
that I think it's a good question thank
sorry thank you for the question um I
think it's a good question um and and it
goes I would go back to that it charter
schools are not we do not approve
charter schools and they we do not have
any oversight of them so that the the
reason we did theou was to provide some
oversight if we were to repeal that I
would ask that we consider something
else every other school has to have any
resource room or self-contained
classroom approved through my office um
we have to go out we have to see the
classroom we have to make sure that
they're certified teachers that's not
the case for for Charter Schools um so I
think there's a lot of different things
that we could look at if if this is what
you were going to repeal I'm just
concerned that if you take this there is
there's nothing else there's I have no
recourse for anything if there's no I
don't even have recourse with theou to
be honest but there's nothing um nothing
overseeing that special
education um would would I heard um
testimony about a OU template yes um was
that something I didn't catch was that
something the department came up with or
Y as part of the legislation um it said
that we needed to develop a template so
we worked with um both the assoc the um
St School administrators Association and
the charter organization to develop
theou and then um our commissioner
reviewed it in the end and then it was
submitted to the districts as a template
for them to use but it was not in the
legislation it was not required right
would it be possible to get a copy of
that template
yes um further
questions see none thank you very much
thank
you and I I see no other cards um for
this bill so uh we'll close the
hearing and in five minutes start uh the
hearing on HB
699 oh yes yeah
[Music]
y yeah
hold
up shoot me
both of us
yeah
e
e e
this
uh this is House Bill 699 relative to
special education definitions and the
prime sponsor is here with
assistance um uh representative katab
please introduce the
Bill thank you chairman cordelli and
members of the House Education
committee House Bill 699 was entered at
the request of the NHD following a
special education audit to ensure
Federal compliance and the two biggest
things that this bill aims to do is one
ensure that children are receiving
specialized instructions such as reading
from qualified reading Specialists
rather than parent
Educators as required under the Ida and
two to add a definition of educational
environment to clarify that approval
from the bureau is required for such
environments which is aiming to prevent
children from being placed in unapproved
or inappropriate environments such as
store storage closets or boiler rooms
and yes unfortunately this has happened
and we need to make sure that this does
not happen again unfortunately there's
been a rapid spread of of misinformation
about the bill which has caused much
concern to
parents regarding their children's
services and thinking that they're going
to be effective I want to address the
points that have been brought to my
attention and provide accurate
information and hopefully alleviate the
concerns about the impact on children's
services one
the
definition um of related Services being
eliminated is not taking away related
services from children it's simply
removing an unnecessary and incomplete
definition in Ed rules we default to
this the federal definition as it's
really well defined a nearly three-page
definition for that one definition this
definition takes the beginning of that
definition and leaves so many needed
items out of that definition
and I want to again specify that this is
not taking away any related Services it
is removing the definition it is not
removing related services from the rest
of the statute nor from from children's
IEPs it wouldn't be compliant with idea
to do so furthermore it is not
redefining educational environment that
that was never previously
defined it's not it's not at all
intended to mandate the special
education service be exclusively
provided outside of the general
education setting the least restrictive
environment principle still applies and
decisions will still be made by the
educational
team um this bill is clarifying that the
bureau retains The Authority for
approval so that we ensure that these
environments are appropriate I have put
in an amendment to clarify that
educational environment is special
educational environment so that when
you're looking um at
2- a instead of saying educational
environment it'll say special
educational environment and then further
down where it's saying where Services
can be provided it it still says in any
educational environment as determined by
the IEP team so we're not at all
mandating that they can only be there I
also want to clarify that we are not
taking away services for the
functionally blind it's eliminating an
unnecessary definition without affecting
eligibility for these Services just as
we don't Define death autism Etc this
definition isn't needed there's an
entire statute on the education of the
blind in
186b so again we're just trying to clean
up some of these definitions we are not
taking away any services from children
and I do think that the bill is very
important because I do think we need to
make sure that we have our children
educated in appropriate environments and
not inside of boiler rooms and that our
children are receiving their related
Services by appropriate and qualified
Personnel not parent Educators I'm happy
to take any questions on this Bill thank
you questions yes represent
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for coming forward with
this bill so I just for
clarification this bill does not take
any transportation Support Services
placement in a residential facility a
medical IAL Services away from children
in need is that correct that is correct
it absolutely does not take any of those
Services away thank
you represent W talk thank you CH good
morning thank you for being here um I
just want to be clear you said that this
bill came from a result of the audit
okay um in crafting the the intent of
the bill removing definitions changing
that and I understand what you're saying
about not taking away any related
services but intent of refining the
definition of those things who did that
come
from it came from Miss fette oh came
from the doe yes okay thank
you um I just wanted be clear um related
Services uh
Roman um five I guess on page
two that is covered under Federal Ida
law and there's no change there so we
are bound by federal law in that regard
correct that's absolutely correct our
definition was the beginning copy and
paste of the federal definition but
because the definition is three pages
long it removed a lot of the needed
definition in there and we don't want
anybody to think that they don't need to
provide the rest of that so it's we need
to default to the federal statute in its
entirety which is what it does in Ed
rules thank you and I did put together
um an amendment just to clarify a couple
of the words it just came in so
unfortunately they haven't had a chance
to print it yet but I will get that over
to you thank
you yes representative Bon uh thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question I'm just curious why remove it
in its entirely as a definition and why
not just put it in as and reference the
federal um citation because it does
appear that it's being taken out for you
know just just by looking at it um so
would a reference
help thank you for the question so I'd
be happy to do that but there's a lot of
other words in here that we don't Define
that we do default to the federal
statutes and so I think when you start
getting into that we would have a lot of
definitions where we're saying refer to
the federal statute it does say in it
does say within the document that we
need to make add rules that
that implement
the statute and within the Ed rules it
does explicitly say related Services
means related Services as in CFR and it
gives the exact reference to the federal
definition so I think we would just get
to a repetitive point if we did that for
every
single piece within the within all
within our statutes it would just be
very lengthy potentially I'll followup
yes um I'm just uh referring to a
conversation uh from Miss Benton that
was very specific about if if we don't
have something that points directly to
legislative statute and that's where the
rules Come From so that's my concern is
that that she was very specific in
saying that um rules reference the
statute um I know that Miss Fenton will
be here this morning and also miss fette
said that um she she might be able to
answer that better if the committee
feels like that is the best way to go
and if the attorney agrees that that's
the right way to do it I'm
definitely happy with that resolution I
do not want anybody
to be anxious or have a misunderstanding
that their children's services are being
taken away I would never ever support
such a
Bill thank you yes representative Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question and simple could you just
repeat what you said about adding the
word
special into education environment and
tell me what lines that was on and I
think it was two places
yeah so it'll be um 186
C2 um mean what lines in the bill I
think it's line seven on page two page
two line
seven thank and was that the only place
yeah thought there were true well that
right there and then within it it also
says I'm sorry let me grab a copy of the
bill so I can just
also on line 10 where it says
educational environments it'll now say
special educational
environment thank you for the
clarification you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you for clarifying things for
us our next Amy te's
um hello full disclosure I'm a mom and
I've never done this before and it is
intimidating um but I'm also uh confused
because I prepared my remarks in advance
based on believing that my children were
going to be losing a lot of things that
they deserve and benefit from
so do I tell you my position on that or
or
not um okay briefly you could you know
express your
concern my name is Amy wheeler teas I
live in ashwa if I could if you have
written testimony also we could pass it
up to the when you finish okay
yeah and I'm the proud mother of three
children I vehemently oppose House Bill
699 on the base of egregious
discrimination and moral corruption I am
respectfully pleading that each and
every one of you oppose this bill and
here is
why two of my children were born with a
rare genetic disorder called SoDo
syndrome their SoDo Syndrome causes
physical and cognitive disabilities but
by and large they are typical bright fun
spirited and capable children Frankie is
a clever and affectionate 10-year-old
boy who is in the fourth grade his
sister Magdalene
is a helpful and courageous 9-year-old
girl in the third grade both Frankie and
Magdalena love to attend their NASA
Public elementary school and are eager
to learn in the classroom every single
day they have made numerous friends with
peers and charismatic and our
charismatic contributors to their
general education
classrooms in order to overcome their
physical and cognitive challenges they
utilize supportive Education Service
such as occupational speech and vision
therapy which allows them to access
their entitled free and appropriate
public education under the individuals
with Disabilities Act thanks to these
Services Frankie and magdalina are
learning to read write spell add
subtract learn geography of New
Hampshire New England the country
identify the planets of the solar system
and so much
more attend in the classroom with needed
assistance allows them to reach their
full potential removing them from the
classroom or stripping them of needed
Services would be debilitating just as
importantly the entire student body and
school Community would suffer great
consequences by their absence my
children with SoDo syndrome are not less
than they are Whole Body and Soul
Children that deserve every ounce of
educational opportunity that any child
without SoDo
deserves I find this bill abhorent
ignorant and hateful I have been a proud
Granite stator for my entire life and I
assure you that this is New Hampshire
can do better than this we were the
first state in the nation to integrate
our disabled students in their Hometown
Public Schools back in
1991 I know this because I am a better
person today for having been a student
in the town of amers during the 19 90s
we are not a state that is going to
segregate and
exclude I find it despicable that
elected officials in our state are
trying to dismantle our public education
despite the majority of constituents
such as myself not being in
favor legislation like this furthers the
segregation it puts a Target on children
with disabilities and it also puts a
Target on children who utilize our
Public Schools
thank you thank
you questions see none thank you very
much for being here oh represent Freeman
I'm sorry thank you so much for coming
in front of us
um your your letter was very hotf and I
appreciate that given what you heard
from the prime sponsor of the bill do
you feel a little bit better knowing
that that's not what the intent of this
bill is
for I do if I know that that's being
held but but as a citizen who's not
participated in this forum before I
don't trust 100% that just because
someone said it and it's on record how
do I know that after everyone approves
it that they don't go turn around and do
exactly what I just said I'm afraid
they're going to do so I I need to
understand in a general sense how that
is truly something I can count
onk if if I could just speak I guess for
myself um we have dealt with special ed
services since I've been in the
legislature starting in
2012 and I think we have always um as a
a legislative body um tried to work for
better services for those children with
disabilities and I don't think that that
will change anytime in the near future
well I appreciate that but one thing
that I am still a little concerned about
is this term of of an appropriate
special education uh environment um and
I cannot stress to you enough and I am
the living proof of it I went to Sagan
High School from '92 to 96 and I had two
um former lonia State institution
students who went to school with me for
those four years and it made a damn big
difference to me and my classmates and I
cannot iness stress enough that my
children Frankie and Magdalena to be in
the general education environment as
much as possible yes there are times
they need to be pulled out for certain
instruction but so help me God I do not
want to see that the definition of a
special education environment means they
are secluded in some sort of classroom
at the end of some wing and they are
never integrated with with peers who do
not have the same
disabilities where's my insurance on
that if I'll just read from the
amendment that we just got this this
moment um special education environment
replaces what's in the bill this is uh
in the amendment special education
environment means a special education
setting that has received approval from
the bureau this environment is managed
by the school district and serves
children with disabilities as specified
in their individual education program
when they are removed from their general
education setting special education
environments are resource rooms
self-contained classrooms and early
childhood special education programs
okay so that's my concern doesn't say
general education
classrooms my they my children should
not be locked away in a special
education resource room for the entire
school day they need it for certain
services and they thrive in their
regular classroom and so do the students
around them who are learning to
understand that some kids have a
communication difference some kids might
have a physical difference where my son
needs to stem and clap there's a lot of
things that the other kids are learning
about how Frankie and magdalina are
equal they they are not freaks of nature
and they're not um to be to be cast
aside in some room so I guess I am still
in opposition of this okay thank you
very
much
uh yes representative Hall thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um part of this bill when it
was introduced it said it was to make
sure that the student said specialized
instruction and not to be dealt with
Paras or whatever has that been a
concern of yours with your
children um it is I think that the
amount of instruction that are being
left to the Paras is very unfair to the
Paras um we've had some very good Paras
with my children that I love and respect
and they go above and beyond for my kids
but they really are not being um paid
for that job um so
uh at least I I can only speak for naswa
and in naswa I am quite vocal about um
the need for par of support to be
increased
greatly thank you representative
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you so
much for being here and um moving past
the feeling that we're intimidating we
don't actually mean to
be I would encourage you to continue to
be attentive and
visible with respect to my colleague we
have worked hard in the legislature to
support special education services and
quite frankly everything is vulnerable
to Dollars and
sense please join us in education
funding talking about this thank you
okay thank you
rson of
Woodcock thank you um thank you for
coming here I just want to first thank
you for your passion as an advocate for
your kids here I know it's not easy
first time or second time or any time
and that come out public like that thank
you so much and secondly I think you do
have um reason to be
concerned okay well thank
you thank you very
much I'd like to call up Rebecca fet
from the Department of Education
thank you chairman cordelli and the
committee um as representative kutab
said we had requested this language as
we were um through our audits we were
asked to look at our laws and rules to
ensure they're accurate and aligned with
Federal language I'm going to go through
the changes for you one by one and I'll
talk about program approval and
educational environments at the end
because it is the Hot Topic um if you
look on your paper on page two line 17
we corre Ed the language in the
definition of speal special education to
align with the federal language that
specifies that it is specially designed
instruction not instruction specifically
designed on page two starting on line 19
we took out section five as it is
verbatim the federal language in 34 CFR
3.34 related to related services and as
representative kutab said it is a much
shortened version um so this would this
steers us back to that Federal language
this does not mean that we are removing
related Services we are removing the
definition from state law as it is the
exact definition partial definition
students will still have the same rights
and protections of the federal law in
regards to related
services on page two line 35 we took out
the definition of functionally blind as
this meets the parameters of the
definition of legally blind and is
included in the federal definition for
Blind and Visually Impaired functionally
blind is not used anywhere in Ida the
state language or federal language this
was all following under the definition
of Blind and Visually Impaired on page
three line 8 we Define specially
designed instruction as there is
continually misunderstanding of what
should it look like in schools we are
ensuring we are meeting federal law by
clarifying who can provide specially
designed instruction and what it would
look like in practice this is where we
said that it's a certified teacher this
is required by Ida that they be
certified on page three line 19 we added
the definition of our special education
information system so back to program
approval and and educational
environments starting on page one line
28 through out New Hampshire laws and Ru
rules the word program is used in
several different types of approval for
districts and their needs needed to be
clarification of what each of these
types of approval are currently program
approval encompasses all district
special education programs all private
priv provider approvals All outof State
approvals all individual program
approvals as well as the approval of
self-contained classrooms and resource
rooms within districts publicy and the
JMA the approval of resource rooms and
self-contained classrooms is a very
different process than the other
approvals and we wanted to clarify the
difference between the two these two
environments are on the Continuum of
environments for students there will be
no change in how we monitor either the
programs or the educational environments
however it will provide Clarity in
working with districts and Reporting on
the different approvals to the public
this does not remove all the other
educational environments such as regular
classroom Hospital homebound separate
School residential it does not remove
any of those it merely clarifies that
for these two educational programs we
need to provide them with
approval that is all it does it does not
take anything else away it says that for
those two we are going to provide
approval which we are required to do per
our laws and rules none of the changes
we are proposing will remove anyone's
rights under and state regulation All
rights are still intact for students
with disabilities I would like to refer
back to representative balon's question
for special education we build off of
Ida ID Ida is the foundation of what we
follow and then state law expands on Ida
so we always have to go back to Ida we
have been we do not reference it
repeatedly because it is our
foundational law so if we have Ida we
always go back to that and then anything
else that we put into law is ex excess
so related Services is defined in Ida it
will stay the same it's just taking up
that partial definition that had been
there before and thank you I'll take any
questions you may
have yes represent thank you Mr chair
and thank you Miss f for the
clarification I just had a question um
the previous speaker raised a concern
about children with special needs not
being um integrated into general
education settings I'm looking at the
amendment that was just passed around
and on line 16 it mentions general
education settings so am I correct in
reading this bill that inter creation
would still be the cing practice yes it
would be um it's we don't have to
approve a regular education en
environment we don't have to approve a
hospital homebound um but we do have to
approve a resource room and a
self-contained classroom to ensure that
they have the correct Staffing that they
have the correct student to teach your
ratio um so and then it helps us to
track how much that student is pulled
out of the classroom so
this is just talking about those two
because I don't have to approve a
regular education environment that's
helpful thank you you're
welcome VOR Woodcock thank you chair
good morning yet again good morning in
terms of the line eight uh on the
amendment or the original no on the
regular on page three please okay uh I I
and
I'm I understand reference back to the
federal statute but it very clear
initiates it says on on a it talks it
has to be provided by a special
education uh instructor teacher
certified teacher my concern is the uh
definition of related service
provider um what is their requirement
for if again mean where it say or
related service provider I'm concerned
that perhaps those people or that person
how how how is that Define so we know
that they are also certified not just a
a a contract Service that may not be
sure so so um all of those Services
require licensing most of that is done
through the oplc um and so a speech
pathologist any of those have to be
licensed they have to be certified in
the area that they are providing those
Services um I mean you could put in
there that they're approved or licensed
or something like that but it's implied
that if you are a related service
provider you have your license to be
able to practice in New Hampshire and
provide those
Services follow yeah just just thank you
just so that that category related
service providers is referencing then
those AR therapy people look okay that
it's not it's not a uh a contract
Service on the outside that has
necessarily bypassing
special well just to clarify it could be
a contracted service but it could be a
certified speech pathologist that's
providing that service so it it could be
staff within the bill but either way
they have to be certified in licensed
they can't just okay thank you thank you
Mr chair resident Murray thank you Mr
chairing thanks for taking my question
um with regard to the amendment which is
28h on lines 30 and 31 um it says um
about closely monitoring to make sure
that each student is making progress and
mastering their goals is there I'm I'm
curious to know whether or not the
Mastery of a goal is something that yes
that is obviously a goal but sometimes
those are in progress in the
learning process so are we um to say
that something has to be mastered at
that moment I I I'm curious about why
that
is we do while they may not master their
goal immediately from that time we would
hope that at some point they will master
that goal that it's not just a a goal
that you put in there and and there's no
progress and there's no Mastery so while
they may not master it the first time
that you put it in the next time they
may so it's it all depends on the child
all depends on the um the goal that
you're working towards
follow thank you I guess my question
would be is it making progress toward
mastering and mastering the goal you
could you could word it that way yes y
yes representative Bon uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you for uh taking my
question so I I recall in the audit and
one of the big biggest criticism was the
um mismatch of definitions and and um
sometimes the state definitions exceeded
what the federal uh Law requires but I
am curious I I understand not wanting to
have the citations all throughout the
bill but um this one specially design
instruction actually does have the
citation from the I um from the ID I
because it's it's we are adding on this
is where we're adding on to the
definition so we added this these a
through e are not part of the federal
definition we've added them on to
provide clarification to the
field so there's the base defition
definition um on 34 CFR 3.39 that's the
base definition of specially designed
instruction and then we've added on this
language to more clearly Define what
that should look
like um yeah so again I'll go back to
the one of the main criticisms in the
audit was um putting on why do we feel
the need to put on additional
requirements to what's already in the
idea because what that was one of the
criticisms is that um
it's getting more specific than needed
to be and this so on this case I think
that we needed to be more specific
because there are many times that um par
professionals or par educators are
providing specially designed instruction
and that is not allowed under idea um
specially designed instruction needs to
be provided by a certified educator or a
related service provider who is licensed
as we discussed SOC it because it was
not it
were while it is additional to it's
while it's additional to what's in the
definition for specially designed
instruction it's clarifying language
that is in
Ida Mr chair just again just it is
relevant to um so what I'm so is this a
problem that's been identified in some
kind of an audit I don't recall reading
this specific issue being identified in
the audit so I'm just wondering what's
the origin why are we doing it so we are
currently under another audit the
special education audit and they are in
in mid process but we do receive from
them um unofficial observations of
things that are that we need to work on
um at the same time when we do our
approvals of resource rooms and
self-contained classrooms and we're
monitoring we have found that par
professionals are providing specially
designed instruction and so we felt we
needed to clarify very clearly that that
is not what should be um
happening let me just clarify also that
there was an audit last year which was
related to due process and there was
another audit on more General special
education um issues uh specifically um
at the
department um that is ongoing now
currently yes R
Murray thank you Mr chair for taking my
question thank you for taking my
question also um with regard to the
underlying bill on page I guess it would
be one uh on lines 24 through 27 um
you're you're referencing acquired brain
y but you're only speaking to acquired
brain injury after birth not potentially
during the birthing process does that
eliminate a group of individuals who
might already qualify because of a an
injury during the birthing process so
the acquired brain injury is a
definition that was within our rules but
we've we moved it here to law um and
that's I did not come up with that
definition we just felt that it needed
to be in law because it is specific to
New Hampshire um I would have to receive
technical assistance on whether we would
change this bill cuz we really just
moved it so that it would be part of
part of law okay I'll just mention that
um I did receive note from the Brain
Injury Association that they have um an
amendment coming a draft Amendment
coming um related to this
section repres Paul thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question uh
on the related Services let's say if a
school district has support Personnel
under speech and language when they go
in and they do the Direct Services are
they related service provider yes even
though they're not certified they're not
no they have to be
certified through through their process
of being a speech language pathologist a
physical therapist a physical therapy
assistant they are all licensed through
the oplc the office of professional
licenser so they're all licensed they
have to be in order to provide those
Services follow
up follow
up so you're saying
the I'm pretty sure that like support
Personnel so you've got you're yes I
understand the speech and language
person is certified but the F those
folks working under them that are not
certified they are not part of this so
par Educators par par Educators par
professionals is that what you're
referring to yes so there's so you would
have certified Educators which would be
your teachers your reading Specialists
um your interventionists all of them
would be certified teachers you have
your related Services which are your OT
occupational therapy Physical Therapy
speech and language and then you would
have um your PA of professionals or pair
Educators who Provide support to those
students directly L they may be
certified because we do provide a
certification through our department but
they but that does not give them the
ability to teach or be a special
education teacher so they would not be
able to provide specially designed
instruction
okay representative Woodcock Thank you
new chair thank you um I I have two
questions one I was going to ask
represent cordelli and I don't want to
put their new chair on the they ask you
but so if I may I just have two first
one is I want to follow up on
representative Hall's comment
um unless something has changed in the
classrooms I've seen over the last 10
years since I've been sitting here and
visiting there are circumstances when we
have special related C certified people
like reading particularly um or speech
who are overseeing the par professional
in the classroom but it's actually when
you go to that classroom often that
professional is in another classroom
there the par providing services are you
saying that's not happening so the par
profession may be Pro May a PA of
professional is there to reinforce or
retach the skills that have already been
taught by either the teacher or the
related service provider they should not
be teaching the skill implicitly so if
the speech pathologist worked on a skill
with the student and then they oversaw
the PA professional to reinforce that
same skill within the classroom or or
retach that that skill to the student as
they were in the classroom so that they
could carry that skill over into the
typical classroom okay may I fall up
with the one I was going to do for you
thank you um just fall I was going to go
through the chair but since you're
sitting there with you're in audit
number three or the this where this came
from but the first two audits that can
have come down or the special education
audit can you tell me where we are in
terms of response public response to
that uh documents of legislation so I
only know of two audits um so the the
first one that was completed was the
special education dispute resolution
audit um that was finalized and it does
not run through my office it runs
through the office of governance with um
attorney fent
however I believe she had said they
submitted their last report on that at
the last fiscal meeting so I believe
that one is done um our audit which is
special education um is not slated to be
done until the end of the year possibly
beginning of the new year okay thank you
chair
sure representative McDonald thank you
madam chair and thank you again in
taking a second look at this amendment
I'm looking at Roman numero 5 and it has
a b CDE e and there's no F but the bill
has a provision f is that left off as
like an oversight or is there a reason
that that wasn't mentioned oh no we
removed it intentionally sorry all right
and is there a reason for that um we had
it was um it was yeah um we had had
heard concerns about it and the way it
was worded there was no other it we just
did not feel it was appropriate to leave
it there once we heard the concerns
about it okay thank you I can give you a
long convoluted story but that's a short
word okay sure
any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Virginia
Canon
M can you just hit your the button
there you go yes ma'am thank you good
morning gentlemen and Ladies of the
committee I want to apologize in advance
if my testimony doesn't follow protocol
I'm afraid this is only the second time
I've ever testified before a committee
and I'm unaware whether there's a
specific protocol I'm supposed to
follow my name is Virginia Canon and I
am a 33-year resident of conquered I the
mother of one child who resided in the
conquered school district and receiv
received special educ Ed ation Services
laid out in her IEP from both an outof
District placement and within the public
school mostly in the general education
setting I was advised by the special
education department that she is the
only child in that District to ever have
12 years of outof District placement and
return to the public high
school additionally I'm a former member
of the Conger school board and I
currently sit on the New Hampshire
Council for autism spectrum disorders
but I am before you today in only my
capacities as a mother to a child with
educational disabilities an adult with
autism spectrum Capa uh Spectrum
Disorder myself who never had the
benefit of support services and a
conquered
taxpayer as I sat down to write out what
to say to this Committee in opposition
to this bill I found that for the most
part I was too angry too frustrated too
overwhelmed to be either rational or
polite
my first thoughts were an internal
dialogue laced with colorful expletives
I felt too angry to even know where to
begin as I sat down to type however my
more logical mind surfaced and I was
able to attempt I hope a more coherent
assessment having heard what the sponsor
of the bill said this morning some of
what I have prepared to say is is not
really relevant because
the intent was not to strip these
Services stripping these Services is
absolutely a violation of the idea it's
a violation of the Federal Regulations
it's a violation of our state law it's a
violation of our state
regulations so a lot of what I did was I
went through and I found all of the
citations and everywhere that it
modified off of where it was supposed to
be going um but if that's not the intent
of this bill then all of that all of
most of my prepared statement is
irrelevant but what I would like to say
to this committee is that if this bill
was an attempt to clarify it absolutely
positively
fails there was not clarification here
witness all the people all the parents
all the family members of people with
special education kids who came out or
are coming out and are waiting behind me
to testify about how this bill can't be
allowed to pass and strip the services
from our kids if that wasn't the intent
of the bill then it sure as heck didn't
clarify
anything the grammar I'm a I'm a policy
wonk or was when I was on the school
board I worked at one time for DHHS
helping to write policy uh worked with
some Jael car really good Jael car folks
drafted policies this I'm sorry all due
respect stinks there are compound
sentences that you can't decide whether
you're making a list or whether it's a
run-on sentence with a dangling phrase
at the end you can't parse this bill
into figuring out what it's supposed to
say quite to the contrary I would
suggest that this bill when it has a
definition from the federal law just say
the definition of special education or
the definition of related Services is as
appears
at 34 CF R 3.39 sub paragraph a just say
that that way parents can go oh I know I
can look it up I can see what it says
don't give me a new definition don't
take it out of there so I think that
it's going to be stripped just say we're
using the definition that the federals
use we're using the definition that the
regulation uses that way parents are not
in an insane Panic that our kids are not
going to get their services I will tell
you the first thing I thought
this says or I thought it said or I
thought it meant to say there were going
to be no outof District placements
because all approved programs are now
within the
district if my child had not been
allowed to go to an outof District
placement I tell you I would be here as
a parent who did not have a living child
anymore she was so bullied that we had
to do an outof District placement for
her Mental Health
without some and if you ask School
District administrators and they are
being honest with you they will tell you
we don't have the resources to meet the
needs of every single kid in our
community we don't have it and I
understand that that's a conversation
for the now split committee to the
finances but to say that everybody who
deals with our kids has to be certified
every everybody I I get that we we
aspire to that but I don't know that we
have the funding for that but we have to
make sure that our kids don't fall
through the
cracks as the other mother and I'm sorry
I didn't get her name spoke our kids are
not less than our kids may be
different great that's what makes us a
community that's what makes multiple
colored leaves on the trees that we love
so much in the fall we're not all the
same can you imagine how boring it would
be if we were all the
same we would have no innovation we'd
have no
creativity but our kids that have
special needs are not less than they're
not a burden they are kids that need to
be supported so they can grow up and be
amazing
adults I just think honestly as somebody
who helped draft some of this stuff 10
years ago and I don't mean this
particular statute
the drafting of this is really really
bad and needs to go back if it was meant
to clarify it
failed I'd be happy to take any
questions if you've got them thank you
representative
Freeman thank you madam chair and thank
you so much for coming in front of us um
before I ask you my first question um
we're all we we're mostly parents on
this board and some of us have children
on the Spectrum like I do so we we
absolutely positively have no intention
of taking any Services away from any
child that has an IEP or a 504 that is
never the intent of it given that I'm
just curious how did you learn about
this
bill I'm a member of a forum group on
Facebook for parents of kids with
special needs and it came across the
Facebook post that this bill was being
heard this morning now it had some
bullet points I please who whoever came
up with the Facebook post please don't
be offended I never take that at face
value I'm sorry I was trained as a
lawyer I I have drafted statutes I my
one of my favorite things you're going
to grown is the Internal Revenue code um
but but that's my autism that's my
there's an answer in here somewhere if
you follow it to The Logical conclusion
there's a definition there's an answer
it it it's convoluted that's for darn
sure but there's an answer here there's
a
definition that's and so when I read
those bullet points and was initially
horrified I said you know what I'm not
going to believe that just yet I'm going
to go and I'm going to read the bill
first and then I'm going to
decide representative
kuger thank you madam chair thank you to
speaking to the beauty of our
diversity I want to ask you are you
confident at this point that the general
education setting is properly addressed
in this amendment of the
bill I haven't seen the amendment okay
um I think it just got passed out to to
to you all this morning I haven't seen
it I I can't speak to that I'm sorry
thank you I I just asked because in my
opinion that is extremely important that
that is covered here yeah I I'm afraid I
don't if you could do please take a
minute
yeah sorry I didn't bring my reading
glasses
that so for example in the amendment
when you look at at
line um seven so you've got a a private
provider of special education that that
would allow the out of District
placement that my daughter attended if
that's if that's what you're
specifically
requesting
um okay so the is this do you want to
get into the nitty-gritty I I I don't
know because my my ASD is really waving
its flag right now but um if if I look
at line 10 where it says this includes
specialized educational environments
comma and the accommodations
modifications and services delivered
within the general education setting to
support children with disabilities and
has approve been approved by the bureau
that's one of the sentences that it's a
compound sentence you don't know whether
it means a individual uh specialized
educational environments and B the
accommodations modifications or whether
it's all a run-on sentence from the
earlier part and then to add the
dangling phrase at the end and has been
approved by the
bureau I'm not clear what that whole how
you parse that whole sentence that was
one of my concerns in the previous Bill
and now my little policy wonk is going
to go back into its cave do you have a
followup yes that's exactly where um I
was confused I just wanted to clarify
I'm looking to know also do you feel
that the classroom setting is covered
here no not
particularly thank
you any other questions
seeing none thank you thank you for
allowing me to speak
sure Lisa
Bowden good morning my name is Lisa
Bodwin strategies for disability equity
I am a Disability Policy professional uh
I'm also a mom and I live here in
conquer um HB 699 contains a couple of
proposed changes to special education
law that are
appropriate however much of this bill
contains confusing contradictory
language as the last testifier
shared um it will stage New Hampshire to
be in conflict with Federal idea
law and I oppose this bill as
written parents across New Hampshire are
indeed frequently infuriated by the
special education process and rightfully
so it is true as rep katab reference
that students end up in boiler rooms and
this is indeed an
outrage so let's assume the bill comes
from a place of good intention seeking
to address issues highlighted by by the
coming incomplete audit as well as
parent
experiences nevertheless as written it
will likely lead to students with
disabilities not receiving a free
appropriate publication uh educa public
education in the least restrictive
environment as mandated by Ida and it
will lead to less inclusion for students
with
disabilities two colleagues who have not
yet been called have spent uh to testify
have spent their entire careers to
advance protections for special
education students and eliminate best
practices in schools across our our
country they they will be submitting
testimony with precise detailed analyses
of the proposed
changes I'm going
to
talk about how this bill Bill's design
removes the presumption of students with
disabilities having the provision of
their Educational Services first be in
the general education setting
so I'm going to say this in plain
language when an IEP team is discussing
educational environment federal law
prioritizes and presumes a general
education classroom setting as the first
location to be considered the place
where a student receives their menu of
supports and services if you have not
heard this enough Ida is never meant to
be a location in a building it is a menu
of supports and services so students can
be staged for academic and social
emotional
success it is only after this
consideration in the first that a
student may receive fape in a more
restricted
environment like self contain classrooms
resource rooms and rooms for delivering
related Services among the many
challenges in this bill the language
literally removes general education from
the definition of educational
environment and while the amendment that
was submitted proposes to reinsert it as
the last
testifier
explained um it it doesn't adequately do
so I want to remind this committee that
that this is not only out of compliance
with federal and state law it is it is
not best practice in education to remove
students with disabilities from general
education classrooms more than 30 years
of research on inclusive education
indicates that students with
disabilities who are in general
education settings achieve better
academic and social emotional outcomes
than students who are in more segregated
settings moreover this committee should
know during the last 10 years replicated
studies now indicate that when students
with IEPs are in general education
settings students without disabilities
also have better social emotional and
academic outcomes substantively HB 699
is entrenching segregated settings for
students with disabilities which is the
reverse direction that New Hampshire
ought to be moving toward and honestly
we should be having bills that mandate
inclusive education as the standard the
gold standard and make New Hampshire the
gold standard for inclusive education
around the country
you can see a complete um my complete
remarks uh in my written
testimony I will I will say that
students with disabilities and their
parents need RSA
186c to reflect protecting the rights of
students with disabilities to have the
same access to their Su School
communities as their peers without
disabilities this bill has many
complications that harm students with
disabilities to obtain fape as parents
attest school districts and teachers
struggle with creating a culture of
belonging for students with
disabilities so districts and teachers
struggle uh so students struggle to
obtain an
education I fear and many others fear
that HB 699 will Prov will provide
school districts with additional tools
to segregate students with disabilities
and broaden the existing Chasm between
parents and school districts leaving
students with disabilities to live with
the long-term consequences this bill
doesn't fix what it hopes to
fix I urge you all to vote itl on HB
699 thank you representative
dry thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my
question if you would consider um that
the definition change was to make it
more specific and and to avoid places
like storage rooms and things and make
these real places to be do you see or
can you show me in here where the
priority of least restrictive means
which is already in the law is
gone what takes it
away in order for me to point that out
to you I need to sit and do a side by
side with the existing law and the and
the bill as proposed and as amended and
I'm sorry I can't do that for you right
now I can get back to you with an answer
to that question that would be wonderful
thank
you represent
Freeman excuse me thank you madam chair
and thank you for coming in front of us
today so um you mentioned several times
General CL General Le classrooms um do
you consider resource rooms to be
segregated I
do may I have a followup sure um so
given that um occupational therapy
physical therapy and spe therapy usually
are implemented on a one-on-one basis is
it appropriate to take the child out of
the general Le classroom in order to
complete those
modalities that's a terrific
question it is important that the
individual needs of each child are
addressed when it comes to their related
Services there is extensive data
indicating that pushing in related
Services is better for students and
their peers than pullouts the challenges
that school districts face is that when
we established special education it
started off in in trailers in
schoolyards and in basements we started
off with keeping them down the hallway
and as as we have
decided to move toward welcoming
students with disabilities into
schoolroom
settings we have discovered different
tools and strategies for making sure
that all students have general education
classrooms as the basis for which they
receive um their educations so schools
have a long way to go in terms of
creating a culture of belonging there's
a lot of Technical and curriculum
changes that need to happen and I would
encourage this
committee to develop legislation to
focus on making sure that schools are
headed in that
direction I would also like to say that
anything that prevents students with
disabilities from being perceived
as uh competent to learn competent to be
your friend competent to be the future
employee of a future small business
owner uh anything that denigrates
students with disabilities as being seen
as viable members of their communities
as adults should not be allowed in our
public schools and when students without
disabilities don't see and experience
their peers with
disabilities uh as valued members of
their school buildings we are going to
continue to see people with disabilities
being ripped off of their rightful place
as Citizens in
America representative Murray thank you
madam chair thanks for taking my
question um one question that I have is
whether or not unintentionally this bill
could um as amended as well um
unintentionally create building
construction environments for future
constructions of buildings um that
doesn't fully encourage the creation of
a building as a whole that is an
inclusive environment for the general
education
setting that's your question that's my
question um so with respect to
um segregating out resource rooms
self-contained classrooms Early
Childhood special education while those
are components of an education we also
want to make sure that the general
education
environments also support Learners in
their least restrictive environment
right as the primary to your testimony
being the general ed class first
currently when Architects and school
boards are putting School building new
school building plans together they
build out segregated settings as part of
the architectural design of school
buildings and I can point to the middle
school project right here in conquered
New Hampshire the first design that was
floated by the school building committee
for the rebuild of the runlet school
included a and in fact a separate
segregated wing for students with
disabilities and parents had to
immediately and swiftly say no thank you
um so the mindset is profoundly
entrenched any other questions see none
thank
you Caitlyn Bernier
hi good morning committee members and
thank you for taking the time to listen
to My Testimony it's a little changed
because of hearing the other things that
um were said so uh kind of going to skip
around a little bit if that's okay um my
name is Caitlyn Bernier and I live in
marac um I am here in opposition of Bill
H of HB
699 um I'm just here to speak about
about how this would impact my family
but I know that it would have U negative
implications for so many um I am the
mother of a highly intelligent
11-year-old girl who just happens to
also have severe double deficit dyslexia
and
ADHD and um I have concerns with the
verbiage and the amendment um that were
made to the approved program on page one
starting with line 20 eight um my
daughter's needs were not able to be met
at her own School District we tried for
a lot of years and unfortunately um
there's not programs in every school for
all the different kinds of learning um
brains that we have and she needed to
get Services out of District in order to
learn how to read this was years behind
her peers so her peers were all already
learning you know learning how to and
she was struggling and not able to and
had a lot of um mental health issues
with it as one would imagine when
everybody else can do the thing and
you're like I'm trying and I can't um
and so she needed to get Services
outside of the district and in the year
that she has been there she's improved
like three reading grade levels just by
being out of the district this verbage
in here that states that the approved
program um there it gets rid of the fact
that it is approved by the State Board
of Education and maintained by the
school district and changes it to within
the school district um that is
responsible for all as aspects of the
provision of special education services
and related supports so if that was to
be put into effect my daughter's out of
District needs would not have been able
to be met and that's not fair to her or
to anybody else that might be in a
school district that doesn't have every
single reading program every single
specialist and every single thing that
you can imagine we worked with the
school we did everything we could for
years and it just wasn't the learning
the way that she needed to be taught to
read um but this would change her
ability to have her out of District
placement her personal goal
despite being out of the district she's
only part-time half of the day now she
went from full day out to only half day
her goal is to get back into public
school with all of her peers she wants
to be like everybody else she should not
be treated differently just because she
learns differently and I think that says
a lot about her that despite sorry Mom
emotion despite being treated different
she wants to go back back and be with
people and show them that she doesn't
treat people different just because they
might be different she wants everybody
in her school just like I want her to be
able to be in a school with everybody
else um so uh sorry got a little
emotional
um uh so the um verbiage where you would
take her uh ability to be out of
district and put it in control of the
district the school district itself um
eliminates her options and my option as
a parent um I shouldn't have to pull her
from public school because we're not
able to find a way to meet her needs um
public schools for everybody so we have
to be able to make everybody's needs met
um and then the last little bit um some
they had spoken about how um the speech
and language um uh teachers are all
certified but there's also like
assistants that are there and there's
reading Specialists that may not be
licensed through the state as a thing so
I I think that that's something to be
taken into consideration when they were
talking about how it's um uh
representative Hall you had mentioned
that there might be people that aren't
licensed and that would be the
Specialists the reading Specialists the
speech and language assistants um that
are maybe going through things but
aren't uh certified they would be
eliminated from that um I think that if
this bill like many have said was to
make things more clear um it just posed
more questions rather than adding any
clarification thank you thank you
representative Hall thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm curious with the out of
District placement was there a special
reading program that was used yes it was
it was um a combination of special
reading programs that were used that
weren't used within the school it was
lips and Wilson but also um using uh
just like some of the um speech to read
versus like uh spe text to speech to
text versus text to speech is how she
learns and we kind of teach people by
looking at it and then saying it and she
needs it the other way around and that's
not really in a public Ed yet I mean it
could be but not yet thank you so much
thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much
she Amy Gerard
good
morning representative katab Dr cordelli
who's not here at the moment but and
members of the education policy and
administration committee thank you so
much for um allowing us to be part of
this discussion and to have an open
discussion about what it is that um we
really need in our Public School
District I'd like to share with you if I
may with the permission of this
committee and the chair my daughters um
alternative and a augmentative and
alternative communication device is that
allowable uh we don't really do props
okay I think it's important though for
you to understand I'm not do if you can
just describe it I can show it to you I
think it's important
because it is what she uses to
communicate and I think that
this is an important prop if you will
although I don't agree with that
terminology um but it's an important
example of how important related
services are to general education and to
the services of people with
disabilities I am here to oppose H Bill
699 because I think it is very unclear
and it
SWS distrust amongst our community and
amongst this the representativ of the
State of New
Hampshire I live here in Conquer New
Hampshire with my husband Chuck crush
and my daughter Alison Gerard Ali
attends conquered high school and is a
senior this year she has had a rich
education with classes such as chorus
where they have performed in Boston
Street Law class where they have
prepared and acted in a mock
trial explored the Bearcat with the
conquered police and as a proud team
member of her High School unified
cheerleading
team Ally is a bright spicy intelligent
young woman who loves to laugh hang out
with her peers and be a part of high
school
life she has a diagnosis of Angelman
syndrome which is a chromosome 15
disorder and it affects gross motor
skills fine motor skills and speech
hence she needs her communication
device which is not a prop
excuse me but in this room it is not a
communication device I I hear you and
the reason that I brought it is to show
the committee exactly what she needs in
order to access general
education as she is unable to verbally
communicate she requires the use of an
augmentative and alternative
communication device seen here it
provides her with robust communication
where she has access to words to
describe her day her classes her
feelings and to boss ala around to
request music and
movies this device is sophisticated in
nature and requires an a specialist to
program it and to teach Ally and others
how to use it she is able to use it in
class at home and in the
community it provides her with a sense
of agency and it is a window into her
life and into her
soul alli's educational team is also
supported by physical occupational and
speech
therapists throughout Ali's educational
career they have provided in-class
resources for her to access general
education
including appropriate seating for course
strength maximum comfort for learning
adaptive equipment for art and assisted
her to participate in
yoga Ali's inclusive education in the
conquered school district has and will
continue to provide her with a unique
educational opportunity to explore who
she is as a person and a lifelong
learner she has a self-confidence that's
contagious a curiosity that's enviable
and a smile that lights up the
rim this is in large part due to her
meaningful inclusion in general
education that is
promoted the values of learning within a
larger
Community this bill as it is written is
confusing at best leaving much to
interpretation and has the distinct
potential to promote seclusion and
isolation by the words used to define
the education of students and
disabilities the late Christa mff a
teacher at High who would have been the
first teacher in space once said I touch
the future I
teach all students including those with
disabilities are an invaluable part of
our community's country I'm sorry
invaluable part of our country's future
they deserve inclusive education that
provides them with what is
possible thank you
thank you any questions representative
Murray thank you madam chair and just
for the record I would just like to
clarify this is um not a prop with all
due respect is this piece of assisted
technology that was approved yeah I I
understand that we just generally don't
allow a show and tell basically from
when you're
testifying thank
you representative NATO thank you madam
chair thank you for all coming and
testifying so we can get a really good
grasp of what's going on um as far as
the current uh
law uh would you revert back to that or
what about getting with the uh current
one that's before us and the amendment
specifically I guess so we're not
looking at discriminatory uh I know of a
12-year-old that is helping somebody in
their class that's nonverbal and we need
to integrate everybody into society and
grows make them into adults so uh would
it be better just to go back to the
original Law or amend the
amendment I really can't speak to that
only because I'm not um well versed in
policy but what I can tell you is that
there have been people here that have um
provided testimony on what would be the
best course of action here I do think
that the the wording in the original
document was confusing at best I think
that the amendment clarifies it a bit
what I can tell you is that any
that
would raise confusion as to where
education takes place um would only
serve to create segregation with kids
poor kids with disabilities it really
needs to be extremely clear in the law
that we are providing general education
to all students where it's the least
restrictive
environment well uh I agree we need to
integrate these children in in the
learning
environment and
um so so we're not discriminating uh and
uh so what I'm saying is would you get
with
the uh the bill here the amendment and
try to amend mat that uh as far as being
Clarity is concerned if you're asking me
if the amendment goes further with um
clarification I believe it does but I
think there's more work to be
done any other
questions oh represent
moris hello thank you for taking my
question um this is regards to the
special education environment um as we
heard from the prime sponsor where we
had some situations where students were
being put in boiler rooms it sounds to
me like we might want to put an
amendment to the amendment to make the
general
education um standard be the classroom
and if for some reason the child has to
be removed temporarily from the
classroom they don't end up in boiler
rooms but instead can be in a
more classroom type setting temporarily
until they can return to general
population uh so I guess yeah sorry my
question would be would you be on board
with that I think so obviously I do not
want any
child anywhere to be taught in a boiler
room I think that's pretty um
self-explanatory I think that we need to
go back to the people that really
understand policy and really Hammer this
out to make sure that we don't have any
unintended consequences I am not a
policy person what I can tell you is
that my daughter has had a really good
experience at the conquered um School
District because of inclusion and
general education
any other questions seeing none thank
you thank
you we're actually very far behind um so
knowing the intention of the bill is
there anyone that would not want to
testify
now no
okay I I think we're going to put a time
limit um of 3 minutes on testimony
now just so we can get this moving along
uh Karen Mor
Mortimer okay
someone shy this is my first time and my
son Tyler's first time here so bear with
us welcome come come
on come on over
come exactly this is the teenager like
oh I don't really want to um I just have
to say about the communication device
being a problem I I know that wasn't a
targeted attack but I I bristled to the
student that uses that device it's it's
every bit as functional as his
wheelchair it's it it certainly was no
disrespect y it y yep I I get it and I
think my perspective as a parent with a
child with a disability is different
just a sidebar I'm going to go off
script for a second here um coming here
we went into the state house by mistake
we didn't know we were over here so a
lot of people said oh there's this
really cool tunnel you can go
your elevator is
broken I know and I spoke to four people
I I don't know who they are the the lift
to get down to the ramp um everyone's
like oh that's always broken that's been
broken for a long time so I I feel like
Ada access to to buildings especially
the the state capital that the language
isn't it's not unclear it's not
confusing and yet we still had to go
outside got lost went around we were
almost late so just a a the struggle's
real U my name is Karen Mortimer I live
in marac New Hampshire with my husband
and two children Tyler say hi to
everybody you want to say hi on the mic
say hi go
ahead embarrassed and my equally
embarrassed 11-year-old daughter
12-year-old daughter Katie um who's in
sixth
grade they may have different academic
goals but they share a fundamental right
to be valued and included in in their
school Community both of my children
make meaningful contributions to the
classrooms and thrive in their
interactions with peers and
Educators Tyler's enrolled in several
general education classes in high school
he receives specialized education along
with essential services such as
Transportation speech therapy Physical
Therapy occupational therapy together
his support team have developed a
structured school day that allows him to
be present in some general education
settings while working on his individual
education program goals the
collaboration includes service providers
PA of professionals general education
teachers and most importantly his
peers kind of Off Script just I I was
one of the people that posted something
on on Facebook and start up a lot of I
think panic because as it was written it
was very confusing um in that post I got
into a discussion with a supporter of
the bill who I I kind of said that's
that's my dream is to have Tyler in a
general Leed classroom working on the
things in his IEP but in the general led
classroom not in the learning support
room sidebar the the boiler rooms aren't
called boiler rooms those in some cases
are called The Learning support rooms so
no one's going to say you know Tyler
spent
14 periods in a boiler room it's you
know he was taken to the learning
support room or the secluded classroom
so it's it's a slippery slope um
an example he was in a math class um his
peers were doing long
division he is not at grade level with
his math skills so Tyler was able to
participate and work on his math skills
which are identifying numbers a speech
goal which is saying the number either
verbally or with his speech device um
that has the same software on Tyler
could use that prop here
um how we worked it out was Tyler would
roll a dice with his peers and he would
identify you know that's a six that's a
four that's a three and he would help
his peers who were learning long
division come up
with their math problems so Tyler's not
doing long division but he with in a
class that is teaching long division is
working on his individualized math goal
and a bonus speech goal because he's
working with his peers um so it's the
conversation about whether par
professionals
teach the goals are set by the certified
um Educators but it I don't see how it
could work some someone on that social
media post actually said you know you
expect to work with a special ed teacher
a general ed teacher and a parah or a
service provider good luck with that I
thought yeah that's exactly what I what
I do
want um I'm concerned that some of the
changes proposed in this bill as they're
written and the revisions to the
definitions regarding programs and
environment services and instruction are
continuing confusing at best and at
worst May hinder an inclusive education
experience for Tyler and other students
with support needs the changes could
limit Tyler's access to a typical high
school experience that he very he has
every right to enjoy I oppose HB 699 in
its present form and urge there to be
that it be thoroughly reviewed to ensure
the proposed language does not lead to
more restrictive educational environment
it's crucial to consider the needs of
students like Tyler we Define the
Frameworks of their education thank you
any
questions seeing none thank you all
right thank
[Music]
you Carrie
Duran oh
just hit your
button good morning Madam chair members
of the committee thank you for the
opportunity to be here today my name is
Carrie Duran and I live in wolfboro I am
the legislative liaison for Lakes Region
Community Services we serve uh families
and individuals with developmental
disabilities and acquired brain
disorders but today I come to you as Mom
my 13-year-old daughter Katie was born
with Down syndrome and I too saw as a
parent on the special education family
uh groups about this bill today and I
barely slept at all last night thinking
about it and what I would say today and
I did put together
a a testimony for you but you know what
things have changed a little bit and I
am glad that an amendment has come forth
I am very grateful for the discussion
and the questions that have come forth
I my daughter's going into high I'm
shaking right now I normally don't get
nervous but this really worries me um my
daughter is uh has tomorrow her tour of
the high school and it would absolutely
devastate me to think that she would not
be given the same opportunities to take
any and all general education class that
she would like to um and I really
encourage the committee just to take a
breath vote for this bill to be itl and
think about if we want to make
improvements to the special education
system which I am all for absolutely we
can always improve but if you look at
all the people in this room and everyone
who has testified today I don't think
there's one person here who would not
come together collaborate on a committee
and hear from uh Professionals in the
industry parents collaborators
stakeholders we're all here and we are
ready to to talk and share and come up
with the best improvements Al together
that we can for our children and our
students and I really um encourage you
to take advantage of the fact that you
have so many constituents that are here
for you to answer questions here to
support here to collaborate here to help
and make change and I really would love
to be able to go back to my daughter and
hear about her tour of the high school
and all the classes that she's excited
about taking and to know um to be able
to tell her hey mom came together with
so many other Advocates and parents
today to make sure that your rights are
protected and other your friends your
best friend's rights are protected so I
would encourage you to oppose this
oppose the amendment vote itl and let's
slow down let's really collaborate and
come together and if we want to make
improvements hear from everyone hear
from the people that it directly affects
thank you thank you right on time I do
my
best any
questions thank you very much thank you
very much Carly
finds first
off yep hit it again here you go first
off it's nice to meet you IRL
representative Noble nice to meet you
too Carly
okay now I know some of this might not
be relevant given what the sponsors have
said but just because I'm a baker
doesn't mean I have to sugar coat
anything so here it goes ableism it's
racism and discrimination against people
with disabilities this bill is chalk
full of it taking away resources that
students depen and isolating them from
their friends why I virgin you to vote
no on this
once upon a time a little girl who was
autistic had a support system whenever
she needed a quiet place to eat lunch a
classroom with the teacher was open she
had weekly occupational therapy sessions
there are pair of professionals to vent
to or get help from when spiraling if
she needed a break from classes she was
a loud one fire drill she was worn ahead
of time overwhelmed by massive amounts
of homework assignments were modified
for her over time she developed a strong
sense of self-awareness strengths weak
spots triggers she learned how to
advocate for herself to get what she
needed to succeed she graduated high
school and moved on to one of the best
universities in the nation and graduated
magna laa she became a grown woman
who runs her own small business got in
the front cover of her hometown's
magazine and has been a guest on several
neurodiversity blogs to be a role model
for future generation that little girl
you're looking at
her you that's right I wouldn't be who
or where I am now without the resources
and support I got during my pre-ol years
would you take away a cane or a seeing
eye dog from someone that's who's blind
would you force someone who then needs a
wheelchair to to walk deny someone who's
deaf an ASL interpreter in the classroom
how about taking away an oxygen tank for
people who can't breathe without it if
the answer to all these questions is no
then I suggest you vote a such on on
this bill if you think you can slap
Judith human the mother of the
disability rights movement the one
responsible for the Ida and the Ada in
the face with this a bill you've got
another thing coming my advice vote know
because I refuse to let you take away
what I've depended on from future
Generations thank you any
questions seeing none thank you very
much
Carly you're you're welcome but
seriously it
seriously don't you don't you dare take
away what I've depended on from from
future
Generations Michael
mshen hello thank you committee members
y'all are getting a lot of input um and
some of it may just be out of sheer
confusion
um we've already heard lots of
commentary uh about that uh my name is
Michael mshan I'm from Rochester New
Hampshire born and raised there
currently living there um I've submitted
to you some written testimony um but
given all the information that we've
gained this morning I want to flip over
to just a few specific points and I will
probably resubmit additional information
uh in an attempt to be helpful
um I I think
unfortunately based in Good
Intentions the the proposed uh Bill HB
uh 699 and the amendment that was
submitted um just further confused
issues unnecessarily so um part of it
just maybe the emphasis is on the wrong
cabable um I think if you know people
are concerned about Paris then let's say
something about how we're utilizing
Paris
um uh some specific things I I do want
to make sure to note here
um appreciated and I think it's clear
the definitions for Bureau acquired
brain injury specialed uh information
system great good on those several
others need some discussion and we can
help make those more clear for your
intent uh as well as
um so let me just quickly go through
some things I've heard this morning
around educational
environment adding yet another layer of
definitions for specialized educational
environments seems unnecessary given in
idea we already have definitions of the
Continuum of alternative settings each
of those has have operational
definitions we've deferred to those
historically now adding in another layer
of specialized education environments
seems clearly from the input this
morning problematic and will will raise
concerns um if the bureau is interested
in having extra Focus Fus on three
particular settings and program types
then let's name that more clearly and
and provide that guidance
um general education setting is a
setting for Service delivery for special
education services and I'm concerned
that the the new definitions of
specialized education environment are
going to be really complicating for some
administrators and school Personnel uh
who are clearly already struggling
um in term of related
Services the there's lots of confusion
around this when I first read it I
thought what are they trying to do here
now with a a finer Focus losing the
current
definition does still eliminate some
specific protections to children like
insuring related services are provided
when placement has been court ordered
and guidance for districts regarding
boarding a child nearby the place
instruction those are not in idea and I
hear the bells are ringing and I got two
more points but I will adhere your time
limits is there any questions
representative Hall Madam chair and
thank you for taking my question could
you tell us what one of those the most
important Point left
out uh under specially designed
instruction again if the concern is
about Paras and I share several concerns
there let's specify maybe what Paris
shouldn't shouldn't be doing versus
layering in a requirement to use
certified
Personnel for all of the special
education services um if we're training
and coaching and supervising parents
there are things that they can do that
will be both effective for students and
Le and more cost effective for school
districts I see taxpayer dollar red
flags all over this the way that it's
currently worded uh and that could be
really problematic thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you
can't Lou
Esposito uh thank you honorable chair
and uh committee members um my name is
lisis esposo I'm the executive director
at AEL New Hampshire um I'm also a
resident of Brookline New Hampshire um
as someone who worked directly with
students with disabilities as a par
professional a special education teacher
an advocate a parent and a friend there
are several components to this bill that
are alarming I think we've all addressed
a lot of these points today um I just
really want to emphasize that um you
know I think a lot of us are really
concerned about this bill and I really
like the the atmosphere of collaboration
to try to make this work I think all of
us here want to see students with
special education teach uh special
education um succeed
I I wouldn't call myself a boiler room
teacher but my off my first classroom
teacher when I was um my first year
teaching had office dividers and a
shower curtain for a door um so I I
understand that um my students were um
were for the most part left completely
away from the general education
environment I had to really push to get
them there and it was very challenging
and you know when we when we start the
conversation you know in a resource room
or segregator room um it's really hard
to get back in there um so um I know
there are a lot of arguments about you
know changing the definitions and
removing things um I guess I really want
to emphasize the importance of you know
in New Hampshire we have a a long long
history of making things um you know
better and we shouldn't be stripping
things we should be redefining them and
we should be improving our education and
the federal standards are just at their
basement and I think we could continue
to strive and especially with some
concerns coming from the federal level I
know recently there was a HR 899 which
wants to terminate the doe we're we're
really concerned about that and we start
stripping definitions today and you know
we don't know what's going to come um
from that level too so I think it's
important to really hold um New
Hampshire special education um at the
highest regard so and I have a testimony
that I wrote off but I'll alter it just
based off our conversation today thank
you thank you any questions
representative Murray thank you madam
chair for taking my question and thank
you for taking my question so with
regard to some of the things you
mentioned um regarding sort of the pull
out model that is no longer really best
practice and we're talking about pushin
models and differentiated instruction
methods do you see there being an
opportunity for more clarity around that
type of best practice instruction being
enumerated in the bill or at least a
find somewhere else I think I think more
thank you for your question repres um I
think it' be helpful to really Define it
um pull out Services don't work for
everybody um I've been in models um in
the in the schools where you know it was
primarily pull out but the goal should
be to bring the kid back into the
general education classroom so to
specify that and clarify that in this
bill be fantastic I think this is a
really great opportunity to really
Define you know what this bill should
be representative
Freeman thank you madam chair thank you
for coming in front of us um you stated
that you think we are stripping
definitions but equally do you think
we're replacing those definitions as
well I guess it's a um a little bit of
both I think when we start removing
definitions like functionally blinds you
know we're we're leaving a population
that are relying on those supports to um
you know kind of reestablish what they
need to be um I think redefining it is a
kind of a different conversation I think
we should be adding to our definitions
and forur and clarifying things as
opposed to removing
them any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Bonnie Dunham
I'm glad the microphone's already on so
I don't have to touch it with my jermy
fingers thank
you I'll just slide myself over so my
name is Bonnie Dunham and I live in
miramac New
Hampshire while I believe that the bill
has some was written with the best of
intentions and there are some some okay
things in it and the amendment made it
better I still have concerns about
several of the proposed changes first is
the proposal to remove the definition of
related Services while both idea and the
New Hampshire standards include a
definition of related Services one of
New Hampshire standards references the W
an idea neither include that the school
district May board a child as close to
the place where instruction is to be
furnished as possible and then provide
transportation to and from that place um
to where the child is going to be
receiving that instruction well that's a
rare situation when that would be needed
unless it's included in another New
Hampshire law and I did my best to look
um I it would be lost I would hate to
see it eliminated as an option for
school districts and families who may
decide that that's the way they can
provide a fape to that child in the
least restrictive environment also since
the New Hampshire standards reference
idea um if idea were amended to change
the definition of related Services all
we did was reference idea ours would
automatically revert to whatever lower
standard they set because I haven't seen
them raise their standards a lot lately
um and so regarding the definition of
functionally blind it may be okay to
remove that I don't know I do know
though in 2006 Bill Finn who was the
head of blind services for Vocational
Rehabilitation told the committee that
it was added because um the the U I'm
sorry the national Federation of the
blind asked states to add that
definition to ensure they all had
protections for children with functional
blindness lot's changed since 200 six so
it may not be needed but I'd recommend
checking with future Insight um who
serves parents um children with vision
parents before doing that I'm glad that
the sponsor added special before the
term educational environment um because
it really you just using educational
environment that means settings in every
other place in the law it doesn't it
includes um playgrounds and lunchrooms
it isn't just um the classroom and I I
would like to see something added that
would emphasize that the regular Ed
classroom is the first consideration I
know it's in um the L Provisions but
with all of the concerns that have been
raised today it would be nice to hyper
emphasize it um sorry I
um I asked that language be added to
clarify that a par professional or other
individual um who was working under the
direct supervision of a special
education teacher May assist in the
provision of related of special
education or um or specialized
instruction or may reinforce what the
special education teacher has taught so
that that can happen in the general
education classroom more easily there's
a there's a lot more kids with
disabilities than there are specialed
teachers out there and so I'd hate to
see kids get um get lost along the way
because of that shortage um also this is
picky but specially designed instruction
it says it's defined in idea and me and
means if it's defined in idea that's
what it means and so I think what this
means to say it's to find an Ida and is
and then the extra qualifiers that we
have um and so I would like to recommend
that this be referred to inim study
because I think it can be fixed but um
and I think there are a lot of people
here who said they're willing to help do
that thank you thank you any
questions seeing none thank you
than Jane berson
good morning for the record my name is
Jane Bon bullu I'm the executive
director for the New Hampshire
Association of special ed administrators
and I'm here representing over 300
members of leaders in the field of
special education I'm not going to um
rehash any of the information that's
already been brought to your attention
um as you'll see in in my testimony I
started off with um recognizing the
importance of these rules and that um
it's it's really important for us to get
them right um equally important is that
all of the voices that you've heard
today from all of the valued
stakeholders are typ typically involved
when rule changes uh come about and we
work together collaboratively and our
members um were really taken back and
surprise that all of the revisions were
uh being made and that all of the
stakeholders had not been at the table
for the conversation which resulted in a
lot of confusion today so while well
attend while it was well intended um we
would say that you know we certainly
don't um support this bill and would ask
that um more folks be brought to the
table for further conversation
specifically some of the things that um
our members uh looked at in this bill um
there was concern raised around uh the
definition of specially designed
instruction um it does start off with
Federal rules at least in the original
Bill and then took a New Hampshire twist
um when you look at the bill as it was
written it it talks about especially
design instruction only being provided
by special Educators and related service
providers we know people like um reading
Specialists who are not special ed
certified who are highly trained in
specialized reading programs um should
be able to and and in terms of providing
specialized reading instructions such as
Orton Gillingham be considered as
providing specially designed instruction
you have adaptive physical education
teachers who are providing very specific
PE to students that wouldn't be um
considered specially designed
instruction so I think you know going
back to the federal definition and
sticking to that would be uh really
important so I would just close by
saying from our Viewpoint um the bill as
written even with the Amendments really
lacks Clarity is rather confusing and um
is certainly could use a lot of editing
and changing and I'd be happy to answer
any questions thank you any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you heather Barker
good morning and thank you for letting
me testify this morning um my name is
Heather Barker and I am the SSC director
here uh conquered for the uh New
Hampshire school administrators
Association so supporting superintendent
and central office administrators and
better understanding how we serve our
most vulnerable
population so I um have been in
conversation with the Department of Ed
and other groups around the state and as
um nhsaa we talked about this bill last
week during our our legislative priority
meetings and we were in favor initially
of supporting the idea because it is a
great idea when we can match what's
happening in our state rules with the
federal rules because it cleans up
misunderstandings um people who may you
know misinterpret or narrowly interpret
things so language really matters
vocabulary really matters definitions
really matter and then over the weekend
I um saw a lot of stuff on social media
tremendous fear in the parent population
who are our partners about the loss of
Rights for their children and that was
not I'm sure I was really glad to hear
that the intention of this bill however
given how it's been written even with
the Amendments it really is clear to me
as someone who is
incredibly committed to children and
their needs we need to take a look at
this again because my real concern now
after listening to all of this if we
can't come to an agreement on what it
all means or we change a word here or
word there are we going to be all set
that lack of clarity around those really
important things like the Continuum of
services like not every student can be
educated in the general education
classrooms if we are talking about our
private special ed settings rate setting
and that whole responsibility in our
department of V I don't even see that in
here so I'm wor I worry about people's
good intentions can be misinterpreted or
narrowly interpreted so that's the fear
you're sensing from parents is okay if
it's not clearly stated then they're not
going to provide it to me because some
people have had bad experiences unfortun
unfortunately in serving and advocating
for their children and working with
school district so that narrow
interpretation could be a real problem
around that related Services the license
ing there's differences between licenses
and credentials there's special
education there's related services and
then there's par Educators who are
actually a supplemental Aid and support
and I'm really concerned when I hear
that stuff because frankly the par
educator I I was glad to see that we
have nessus in here right our
information system the electronic one
however listed in the special ed Service
Grid in the dropdown where people choose
who is providing the special education
right now we still have par educator
there I brought it up again the
department edit is working on getting it
taken out but when you have that level
of confusion this is how things like
this happen so I would love to support
Clarity definitions common vocabulary
streamlining making our state consistent
with the federal rules however right now
as it is I can't support it thank you
representative dry thank you and thank
you for taking my question if we did
this in interim study and did all those
things would that be a Absol absolutely
would support cleaning up our
definitions thank you any other
questions seeing none thankk
you Kristen
manani good morning thank you all uh
Kristen monani Office of the advocate
for special education here in New
Hampshire and we are um really more
often than not um articulating parent
voices in disputes over what their
students need so definitely very
committed to ensuring that our students
receive um every piece in the proper
manner of special education to which
they're entitled um I I don't want to
Echo a lot of what everyone said I want
to try to provide some clarification on
a few points but the one thing that I
urge that we not lose is that um we've
had many cases in our office and I know
the Department of Education is aware of
this as well where we do need um some
better legislation
around the question of educational
environments under broad approved
special education programs because we
are seeing over and over and over again
it's not an isolated case instances
where the concept of the
um substantially separate classrooms um
on the Continuum
becomes uh they're really called
self-contained special education classes
become isolated offices spots and
hallways this is where you get the
Boiler Room reference I don't want to
imply that I've seen most of them in
boiler rooms but really in environments
that are both not appropriate not
inclusive
um it's our argument that we're seeing
many of these as being more restrictive
than some of the further down the
Continuum um separate special ed schools
because some of these students have no
peers and this is happening all too
frequently and I think the effort being
made so even as this gets cleaned up I
want to make sure this does not get
abandoned in terms of attention the
effort that's being made I think by the
department of Ed was to say to districts
look you know just because we've
approved your whole special education
program and we've approved a
self-contained special ed class that you
might have that doesn't mean we can
suddenly take certain students and put
them in other things and say well this
is their separate
special self-contained class and this is
that student special education
self-contained
class if we're doing that all of those
environments need to be approved and
more importantly because the word
environment can can become confusing
what it means by these definitions is
that all the providers in those
environments also need to be approved
because that is where we are seeing all
too much time being spent with par
Educators um especially designed
instruction is in Your Service delivery
Grid in the IEP and it has a provider
listed next to it and so there there are
places to put the par Educators in those
Service delivery grids it would not be
called specially designed instruction
the specially designed instruction in
the number of minutes per week should be
provided by a special education teacher
and I agree with the effort if it if if
we have lack of clarity in the Nessa
system such that we can select the wrong
provider to provide specially design
instruction we have to clean that up but
we do need to give the department more
Authority and us more ability to say to
the department to raise an issue please
go look at where this child is being
educated because this is coming up and I
would tell you 20% of our cases we do
deal that doesn't mean it's happening in
20% of the cases Statewide my office
deals with really more more egregious
situations that have gone on for a long
time often higher needs but we want to
make sure that we're giving them that um
ability thank you any
questions seeing none thank you
representative
Hall thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question so would you
support an interm study on this I would
support an interm study and actually I
do support most of what is in the
amendment because I think the amendment
does clarify some important things um
and and just to speak to that related
Services um piece the idea Federal
definition of related Services is much
much broader than what was in the state
um piece it's actually quite good in the
idea um and so by writing anything in
our state that is definitional that
narrows
um we do a disservice right we we should
not be writing any definitions that
narrow and unfortunately I don't think
it's feasible in our legislation to
write in everything that is there in the
idea so so I really do believe that the
intent was take out something that's
much narrower because that actually that
definition had the potential if someone
didn't fight it properly to limit not
expand the rights of students thank you
represent of Damon thank you madam
chair could you please tell us
approximately how many cases your office
is currently involved in and if you have
it roughly what portion of special ed
students across the state that
is okay so we are always going to be
involved in a tiny fraction of cases
across the state um cases across the
state for for IEPs to um exceed
30,000 um we have two full-time staff
members myself and my colleague Tim
Lenahan Hera here um last year we were
very like in a year period um our first
year of operation we were very actively
involved in 40 to 50 cases in terms of
resolution most of the time it was just
me at that point um right now we are
getting inquiries that are you know not
even just inquiries requests for
assistance that top about 40 a month we
are not coming close to be we simply
just are so radically understaffed um I
would say at any given time you know Tim
and I are each actively handling
probably about 10 cases in addition to
trying to weigh in on policy and um ra
you know meet with doe and raise issues
that could be
systemic any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you and that will close the hearing on
699 we do still have a couple of
hearings left and we're going to break
for lunch and be back here at
1:00
e
e e
um thank you we'll get started again we
have uh two hearings um left from this
morning starting
with House Bill
754 which is establish in an automatic
Discovery and due process hearings for
actions seeking to enforce special
education
rights and um since I don't see the
prime
sponsor
or any of the
co-sponsors uh representative uh Terry
has volunteered to uh introduce the bill
for us
thank you Mr chairman I'm representative
Paul Terry from representing Alton and
baret and I'm here to uh introduce uh
house bille 754 on behalf of uh the
sponsor Andor co-sponsors none of whom
appear to be present at the moment but
to get the ball rolling um I'm uh
introducing the bill and uh no I would
prefer not to take any questions okay
thank you very much for that
and uh uh we appreciate your
introduction and I do have um one card
uh that is Kristen
Mami the uh office of special education
Advocate good afternoon yes Kristen
monani here with the office of the
special education Advocate thank you all
for giving me the opportunity to testify
on this
uh we the office supports a version of
automatic discovery that I do want to
talk about um here today we don't
support this bill as it's written and I
will tell you why um we have submitted
to the prime sponsor um what our
proposed language would be for a redraft
of this so to define the term Discovery
I think those of you who are lawyers
understand it but otherwise it's kind of
a gene general term
um when we're in the process of dispute
resolution and so so this in some
respects can address a finding of the
special education dispute resolution
audit which really called for efforts to
make the process more open to parents
pray a lot of parents came forth during
that audit conduct and said we're paying
anywhere from 10,000 to
60,000 fees to advocates or attorneys to
even bring our cases to some kind of
resolution so you know that shouldn't be
the case because really in terms of
accountability for our special ed
dollars and for outcomes um parents
should be able to bring uh situations to
resolution when they don't believe the
services are accomplishing what they
need which is making adequate progress
for a student
so um a version of so-called discovery
which is the process by which all the
documents get produced that support um
or oppose a position taken in a case um
there there are a lot of rules around
that production of documents sometimes
there are motions for against the
production of documents they it gets
argued out before the hearing officers
but the whole um kitten Kaboodle of
producing documents is is the Discovery
um what we what my office has found in
working with parents over the past year
and a half and we have
had occasion to be in due process
hearings on a number of times is that um
sometimes the points really get lost in
thousands and thousands of pages of
documents that are being produced it's
overwhelming for a parent pray um if the
parent hires an advocate or attorney
because it's not a case that our office
could take and and we are working in
only the tiniest fraction of the cases
that come up um you know that is just
time time for our hearing officers time
for the parents to go through these
thousands and thousands of pages and
really special education
disputes if we're looking for
accountability and transparency should
boil down
to progress reports
evaluations and something called the
written prior notices which is the
document by which a parent might have
said I'm requesting X and the school
district says yes or no and gives their
reasons why it's a required document
there's a written prior notice we
acknowledge that you've requested this
and we're saying yes or we're saying no
and we're basing our answer on the
following these evaluations these
progress reports Etc so our office would
would very very um heavily support a
bill that
said yes every case that comes
up there is an automatic Discovery
before the first conference with before
the prehearing conference confence which
is the first time that the parents get
in front of the hearing officer or both
parties get in front of the hearing
officer most of the time and what gets
produced by the district is just what's
in the enumerated list here my issue
with the bill the reason we're not
supporting it is because the paragraph
before the enumerated list under sorry
let me turn my
um
uh it's numbered a bit wrong here I
think in the bill but three R num
3-b we're not supporting what's in that
paragraph a there because it allows for
the same dump of data that I'm talking
about that can really obscure issues and
thousands and thousands of pages we are
supporting the idea that what's listed
in this um B such discoverable items and
information are I would strike the shall
include but not be limited to um and
then a list of pieces because those
would make the process of dispute
resolution far far more accessible to
the parents it would actually let the
hearing officers know what the case is
about for the most part here if the
hearing officer gets several thousand
Pages they say to the parties you tell
me what to focus on I'm not reading
through all these several thousand Pages
um so it puts actually a procedural
burden on the parent during the hearing
to know how to reference the documents
virtually and have a witness who brings
them in ETC it creates a lot of Burden
um and it just does not allow for the
really clear issues to come forward um
to give some examples I had a couple
cases um in the past few months where we
had sort of had to prove a negative we
had to prove that on the parents behalf
that there weren't progress reports it
sounds easy except that in thousands and
thousands of pages of documents that
were
produced we were in a position after
endless hours of hearing of saying to a
witness
well where where is your evidence of
problem
ress point us to the progress reports
well I'm sure they're in here I mean I
do you want me to say I I I can't I mean
sitting in the hearing go through the
thousands of pages and I sort of made
the point but I'm not allowed to testify
as an advocate I have gone through them
are you certain you know can you point
us to the pages well not right now but
I'm sure they're there so it's a very
odd position of having to kind of prove
a negative that they're not there in the
many thousands of pages when these cases
should be simpler and and it would hold
District accountable for Progress if
every single time a parent filed a
complaint The Next Step that happened
was great produce the last three years
of progress reports evaluations and your
written prior notices where you said
whether you were granting or denying a
parent request and on what basis and
that's it don't produce any more than
that just produce that to the hearing
officer so that he or she can digest it
and and there can be active management
of the case and a hearing officer or
even a school district um representative
who's just taken over a case which
happens many many times can themselves
say let me look at this before I
continue to prosecute this case let me
look at whether I do actually have these
basic simple documents that should be
the accountability piece so we do
support a version of this bill and half
provided language that amends what's
here what's here I fear would just
require something that I think is
actually a negative which is a huge dump
of information
because it's saying give us everything
that shows the appropriateness of the
placement and it would include these
documents but not be limited to them I
think that less is more and actually
requiring the more is a disadvantage but
some version of automatic Discovery
would be a huge huge change in our
processes and very beneficial to Pro
parents thank you represent Murray thank
you Mr chair and thanks for taking my
question so when you're talking about
prosay parents that means they're
obviously representing themselves yes um
so you're using that definition but
you're not using the definition of
Discovery in the traditional legal sense
that it is open to a broad swath of
things you're wanting a more narrow
scope defined by those progress reports
what are the other two um so so it is
what's written here um it's it's number
one would only apply in certain cases so
in our redrafted Amendment we say only
when the eligibility is that issue in
the first place um but it's the IEP
drafts that the written prior
notices
um we rewrote it as evaluations and
progress reports um to your point no uh
and and in the language we've proposed
we do say you know it would be
inappropriate for this legislature to
try to limit the discovery that's
permissible above and beyond what we've
termed core documents that would still
be permissible for either party to
provide um saying we need to supplement
to make our Point these basic core
documents but what we would like to see
is that as soon as you know the first
step in a hearing happens those
documents that parents may have received
at some point in 3 years probably
electronically a lot of parents don't
even realize the importance of the
written prior notices um from a legal
sense that these documents would be
would come up in a very standardized
packet that every hearing officer knew I
can look for the wpns par notice the
progress of reports the
evaluations and get a sense of this case
and then additional Discovery um you
know is provided under the rules and
very much delineated and it would it
would have to continue to be allowed
we're not trying to okay rewrite
that representative Hall thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so where is the language that
you proposed um we we did submit it to
representative Murphy and I can
circulate it to this full committee or
or to the chair and ask that he
circulated thank
you representative Damon yes thank you
Mr chair thanks for taking my question
yeah in the vein of you if you don't
know you should ask what is a written
prior notice I get the written part sure
so every single time that a parent
requests or that a school district
proposes to make um a substantive change
and and and that's further defined but
essentially something that changes the
placement of a child services that a
child is receiving under special
education um The District's required not
only to kind of hold the meeting and
discuss that but actually put in
writing the proposal whether it came
from the parent or the district if it
came from the parent whether they're
agreeing to or denying that
proposal and the basis so usually it's
it's pretty streamlined it would say
parent requests
specially designed instruction in
writing District refuses to provide that
because on the basis of the progress
reports Etc or this evaluation we don't
think it's needed a big one that comes
up more substantial than one specific
service parent requests an
outplacement District refuses on the
basis that the student is making
adequate progress as demonstrated by the
progress
reports so again we're just saying okay
this is a legal document this is really
where a case should be based we should
not have cases going to
hearings unless something specific has
been requested has been denied with a
basis expressed which is what the
written prior notice is required to do
um for that denial and and that denial
basis usually can be find found in
progress reports or
evaluations what what it's important to
understand is that these are these are
very legal documents often receive them
alongside they receive this written
prior notice and you almost kind of
brush it aside because it's received
alongside a very large packet of IEP
documents sometimes um making amendments
Etc uh its significance is sometimes
overlooked and it is hard for parents
because they are receiving tons and tons
and tons of documentation to really have
a good case File they don't think when
they're having these discussions back
and forth with their school district
that they're eventually going to end up
in a he ing on these pieces so parents
have not always retained them the school
districts are required to in the files
we're just asking automatically produce
a case File that is streamlined that the
hearing officer knows to look for these
items every time and it will make it
very obvious if they're not there parent
won't be in a position of proving that
the needle is not in the Hy stack there
are no progress reports in these
thousands of pages for this whole year
instead the hearing officer would have
seen that day one where where are my
progress reports I don't have any
District what's going
on representative Woodcock thank you
chair good afternoon hope you enjoyed
the Quick Lunch um here's a question for
you said that you provided additional I
think somebody brought up additional
language to represent Murphy is that so
the language here is not from your
department no it's not okay may fault
thank you so the so that information is
that going to come as an amendment are
you Distributing to the whole committee
or we're not going to see it all right I
will I oh you have it oh I'm sorry yeah
it's not in the form of amendment yet
okay thank you I apologize thank
you represent
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in front of us so
um I'm going to play a little bit of I'm
going to ask you a question if you don't
mind would you not agree that obtaining
all of the stated information should be
left up to the
parents I I understand exactly as as a
parent of a child on the Spectrum for 12
years I went through every IEP process
there was twice du process so I
understand what you're saying but I'm at
an advantage I'm an occupational
therapist so I know how to read those
documents but shouldn't we leave that
decision up to the
parents I just want to clarify the the
decision question so I think
that parents are still free and in the
language we've proposed we are explicit
in saying none of what we're talking
about that should be produced as a set
of core documents to the hearing officer
up front limits in any way the right of
either party to voluntarily submit
additional or to request additional
Discovery thank you followup and I think
that's what's missing is the new
language but I thank you for the answer
thank you represent
Cornell so what you're proposing would
stream like streamline this and make it
easier and the um fiscal note says that
um it's determin will be because you
can't tell how many actions will be
taken but it probably would be less if
parents got this and could understand
more easily what what they needed what
was going on what they were being given
you know I'm having flashbacks to the
last bill which was so confusing that I
don't think anybody at by the end of the
hearing knew what was going on so this
seems like what you want to do and your
Amendment would make it easier for
everybody yes that is that is always the
intention with the idea that more
transparency leads to more accurate
outcomes in terms of the fiscal impact I
would say that merely requiring a set of
core documents to be produced that are
already definitively required to be in
the school district's files and if
they're not there it means they don't
exist often they don't exist that's part
of the problem um not often but but at
times when we're going to hearing but
there should be no fiscal impact to just
requiring a quick let me pull these and
submit them electronically from the
files it should cut down on the cost of
some hearings um for for the even the
hearing officer's time thank you
represent Bon oh thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question um so
you said that this language and or this
bill didn't come from your office um I
know that the prime sponsor isn't here
but do you
know um why this bill is necessary from
the Prime sponsor's position and um why
this specific language uh and where it
came from as is right now I do know um
it was the outgrowth of a conversation
that my office was involved in about the
the process of hearings and we did
suggest that there should be sort of a
hearing packet that was automatically
provided on the basis of our experience
doing some of these hearings and not
having that information with Clarity um
but we were sort of explicit that it
should not go
beyond this core set of documents that
was required because it would sort of
defeat the purpose we did not draft the
language um it is why as I've said we've
kind of wait in to
say the language came from from parents
who who sometimes been strong Advocates
but um you
know we as I said we've provided our
take on an amendment just quick followup
um so these you you what you have said
is this information is often times in
already included in the file um that is
that the school district has to send to
the parent anyway when when they get to
this stage because you refer to a a data
dump um so I'm assuming that part of the
problem from your your the way you're
describing it is that what here officers
need are these specific informations but
they're going to have to dig through the
whole file to get at them is is that a
correct assumption it's it's largely
accurate I would just um provide one
clarification um at the time of a
hearing these documents are not
necessarily sent to the parent these
documents might have been sent to the
parent over the course of a few years
prior and they should be in the school
district's files the school district is
nowhere required to turn over its entire
file the only thing the district is requ
ired to provide is what they feel would
support their case and anything that a
parent knows to draft a discovery
request or in the hearing to
specifically ask for that's actually a
tall order for a parent because though
they know they could ask for documents
they're like in what form how do I how
do I ask for the right things um many
parents we deal with would not even
necessarily know they they wouldn't know
to ask for a written prior notice
whereas I think that's one of the most
important documents because it has to
succinctly
summarize here's we we acknowledge
getting this request here's how we acted
on it and here's why and that kind of
gives you your road map to dive into the
wise and what the data was to support it
um so the at no point in a hearing is
anyone required to turn over right now
these specific documents and we think
that would be a very helpful step in the
process repr Murray thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my question one
question I do have is how this process
would potentially stand in support of or
contradiction to
91a
um so I would tell you once you're in a
hearing setting 91a becomes less
relevant because it really is going to
be the discovery process and the rules
that are kind of laid out for Discovery
um rarely would one of our parties in a
in a in the course of a hearing need to
do a 91a request because they can do a
so-called voluntary Discovery or
production of documents request and it
is presumed that unless a good reason is
Advanced and the hearing officer
rules that documents don't have to be
produced by either party that there is
an obligation to produce whatever's been
asked for the problem is the onus is on
the parent to know exactly what to ask
for and to draft these essentially legal
motions and then argue for why they need
those documents if someone objects so um
it it substantively what you get might
not be so different from a 91a request
but it would in a hearing process be
done under the discovery
rules R WC thank you well last question
I know he like give me two if what I'm
hearing is assuming that we don't have
any other language and assuming that
you're the advoc advocate for the
parents why isn't your office just can't
prepare a simple little request you for
the parents to say these are the things
you should ask
for we can um and we are talking about
doing that and actually that is um to
representative Bon's prior question uh
this discussion came up within a broader
discussion of what are the things that
we can do right now to simplify and to
assist parents for in a formulaic way
with pursuing their cases um again onus
is still on the
parent to to actually ask for that um
fill out that form and and we could
not
um we think there's a benefit both both
for the clarification of the issues
whether it ends up benefiting parent or
District in the end but we also think it
would help our hearing officers to
better manage the cases and to have a
clear picture from day one about what
the issues are that they're weighing in
on so we didn't didn't want to put this
necessarily just on as the burden of the
parent we certainly can do that and and
would in the absence of this legislation
draft that sample form thank you thank
you chairman see no further questions
thank you very much for being
here um and uh there's no one else who
wishes to testify on
754 we'll close that hearing and move on
to um House Bill 753 relative to
expedited do process hearings to enforce
special education
rights and since um he did an such an
outstanding job and introducing the
previous bill um I will ask uh
representa Terry to introduce this bill
as
well we're gonna ask you
questions you might receive some very
interesting answers
responses I should
say Thank you Mr chairman I am here to
introduce uh HB 753 FN relative to
expedited due process hearings to
enforce special education rights and I'm
doing so in the absence of the sponsor
or any co-sponsors and I would prefer
not to take any questions for fear that
the information I provide may not be of
help to the committee thank
you and and we'll remember that for uh
future hearings as well I appreciate
that thank you I hope to be back
sometime thank you
repres um Bonnie
tunham my name is Bonnie Dunham and I
live in marac New Hampshire I'm here as
a regular person um just as private
citizen um and I'm asking you to please
support this bill it's to ensure that an
expedited do process hearing can't take
longer than a regular due process
hearing there are two types of due
process hearings a regular one and an
expedited one and you might think given
the definition of the word expedited
that it would mean it would be faster
but that's not necessarily true a
regular due process hearing is a
procedure that parents in schools can
use to resolve a dispute on anything
having to do with identification
evaluation placement or the provision of
a free appropriate public education for
a child it must be completed and the
decision mailed to the parties within 45
calendar days the caveat is that if a
parent files for that to process hearing
there's an additional um 30-day
resolution period before the 45-day
clock starts ticking and that's intended
to give the school one more chance to
try to solve it um to the parent
satisfaction so so maximum 30 to 40 30
um it would be 45 45 plus 30 75 days if
the parent in the school district decide
to wave the um the resolution session it
would be 45 calendar days but for
discipline related issues including when
a parent disagrees with the decision to
remove a child for Behavioral issues or
when they disagree with whether the um
the behavior was the result of the
child's disability or the result of the
school district's failure to implement
the IEP it's called the manifestation
determination
meeting um or when a school district
asks a hearing officer to remove a child
from their current placement because
they believe that maintaining them in
that placement is substantially likely
to result in injury to the others the
hearing must be expedited the timeline
for an expedited due process hearing is
20 school days um for the hearing to be
held plus 10 more school days for the
hearing officer to render a decision
there's also a 15-day resolution session
that would start periods that would
start before that clock starts ticking
unless the parent in the school district
decided to wave it so that would be 30
school days plus 15 school days I
managed to find um the Manchester School
District's calendar for last year and
this year last year's was hard but I
found it um to give an example so if you
lived in Manchester and a request for a
regular old due process hearing was
filed on June 3rd of last year the
hearing would be completed in a decision
given by July 18th if the was no
resolution session and even with that it
would be completed by August 16th that's
10 and 1 12 weeks after the hearing
request was filed but still in time for
everything to be resolved before you go
back to school but if on that June 3rd
of last year an expedited du process
hearing was requested then the decision
wouldn't be rendered until October 2nd
if there was no resolution session and
October 17th if that resolution period
was used 19 1 12 weeks after the request
was filed that means that an expedited
due process hearing would take between 9
and 11 weeks longer than a regular due
process hearing so you might ask I asked
um why wouldn't the parent in school
district just file for a regular due
process hearing and it's because they
aren't allowed to if it's for a
discipline issue they must file for an
expedite to due process hearing and
there are letters put out by the office
of special education programs that
clarify that yes indeed that means even
if it takes longer
um this bill meets the requirement in
idea that an expedited due process
hearing must occur within 20 school days
and a decision made within 10 school
days after the hearing is filed because
in instances like if it happens over the
summer um 45 calendar days is within 20
school days and so it's it's addressing
both um plus those 10 school days so
this bill would only apply in those
really rare instances when the issue is
a discipline issue and that's why the
hearing was filed and it happens to be
at the time of year when when having the
hearing expedited would mean that it
takes longer much much longer in some
cases than a regular due process hearing
that's just not reasonable we all know
what expedited means so I would like to
ask you to please recommend this ought
to pass to ensure that expedited means
that the hearing will be faster or at
least not longer than a regular due
process hearing and I'm happy to take
questions I've given you like probably a
page full of footnotes in your in the
written testimony so that you can find
any extra information that you're
looking
for thank you thank you
questions uh representative Bon thank
you Mr chair and um I'm sorry I haven't
got gotten time to look through all that
but I think this is a quick answer so
the the the obvious um thing that stands
out to me is the difference between
calendar days versus school days um and
if I understood correctly um it's the
the 30 uh the school days comes from the
Ida theed both they both timelines come
from the Ida um in the fact that the
expedited one is 30 school days for the
decision to be rendered and when that
when that expedited was established it
was because the purpose of the expedited
hearing was to ensure the matter was
resolved promptly and the child's
educational program is not adversely
affected by undue delays that didn't
quite work out the way they might have
intended a followup please yes um so the
only way to rectify the situation is is
change the state law because you can't
do anything about the federal law yes
and and this you're not change the
federal law still says the timeline
still are in place you're just saying
that if it happens to take longer then
it it can't take longer that we would
have to make sure that both were
finished within the the shorter timeline
thank you thank you any further
questions see none thank you very much
is there anyone else who wanted to
testify on 753
see none thank you we'll close that
hearing and we're going to move on in a
couple of minutes to our
um used to seeing
my um yes we have an
session coming up in a few
minutes
e
e e
okay I believe we're about ready to
start our executive session and first
will take up House Bill 677 requiring
schools to maintain a supply of EpiPen
injectors for use in the event of an
emergency um representative Terry uh do
you have a motion that you would like to
make uh yes Mr chairman uh I move all to
pass thank you is there a
second second representative
Murray uh would you like to comment on
your motion well in this instance uh I I
I may speak to the bill whereas on the
previous two I I did not uh that's fine
with us it appears as though we may be
on a track for a bipartisan vote uh on
this bill so I will not necessarily uh
feel that I need to belabor my remarks
this uh this is is a common sense bill
this is a good bill and it reminds me of
the bill that we had last uh term in um
in Commerce with respect to um paddles
uh which uh for coronary events
um there were there were there was a
good discussion around this bill but I
don't recall that there were any um
serious uh defects or deficiencies uh
that were pointed out by by any of us um
and so I think uh we should move
expeditiously to move this bill forward
to the Full House and hopefully for
passage and signing the law thank you
thank you rident Murray any comments
thank you Mr chair no I just think um
that this is it makes sense in the event
of um there being an allergy which we
heard that there are high instances of
allergies where anaphylaxis can happen
so I second the motion thank you any
further comments from anyone else on the
committee no seeing none Madam
clerk yeah when you're
ready Vice chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morse yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Balboni yes
representative Damon yes representative
kuger yes representative Snodgrass yes
and rep chairman cordelli yes 18 y zero
Nays consent okay with
everybody thank you who's writing the
report uh
Terry repr Terry would you write the
report on
that thank
you um there are two bills that um we
were thinking of executing today that we
will uh hold off on um HB 1221 special
advisory coun
um I have to work on an amendment on
that and HB 398 in terms of genocide
studies for people um impacted um who
have
disabilities and we're going to hold off
on that one uh so next we'll uh take up
uh House Bill
68 which
is making uh best interest placements
within the same school district
mandatory in the absence of a valid
reason to deny placement that's House
Bill
68 and um yep representative
McDonald thank you Mr chair I move this
bill ought to pass and I also move
forward an amendment great thank you um
does everyone have the amendment
okay
um I think represented that's um
Amendment 0103 H yes great thank
you um is there a
second okay represent
Morris um would you like to speak to
your motion yes do I speak to the
amendment or to the bill
um you can speak to the um bill as
amended okay uh the amendment in front
of you all was mentioned during the
hearing it just removes the reference to
private schools because that was never
intended to be included um it just
corrects an oversight that was made
during drafting the bill as amended
remedies the existing process of best
interest placements by increasing
communication between superintendent and
parents thus increasing transparency
under current law parents May request
for their student to attend another
school within the same district since
most requests result from unfortunate
circumstances such as extreme bullying
the superintendent typically approves a
request however when requests for best
interest placements are denied parents
deserve to know why and this bill
requires superintendent to explain in
writing why accommodations were not met
within 10 days of the decision and
furthermore this bill requires best
interest placements to be approved
absent a valid reason to deny the
request and then finally this bill has
neither a fiscal impact nor an impact on
districts of only one available school
for the grade level so again I move off
to pass thank you uh anything further
repres no okay any other comments from
the
committee representative Woodcock thank
you we talking about the main Bill the
amendment Mr chair um you can talk about
either if you wish okay well I feel I'm
get the wrong look here but on on the
amendment I'm just concern where it says
shall um that we're requiring the
superintendent to do something uh I
understand the need to have the the
follow the quick followup that was that
was no question there's no there no need
to go beyond 10 days but and I
appreciate that representative from
Salem made that change I still have
concern about requiring the
superintendent exactly what he asked to
do in law in terms of just the decision
before he sees all
data if I can I respond Mr chair yes um
the amended language does not change the
sh the shall appears in the original
bill as well the amendment only removes
where it says approve private school
that free words are changed that's
it yes yes well the last the LA line
nine the superintendent shall approve
the Roy class on less that's my concern
yes and that appears within the original
bill as well the amendment does not
change that
any further
discussion I've seen none
um call the uh the
amendment this I'm sorry chat about okay
about the amendment okay
thanks we will have a brief uh
caucus we're going a very secret pled
to
any other uh further discussion from uh
committee
members this is just on the amendment
the amendment
yes clerk
yes Vice chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative
Freeman yes representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morse yes representative NATO
yes representative
Cornell no representative Murray no
representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no representative
Balon no representative Damon no
Representative kuger no representative
Snodgrass no chairman cordelli yes 10 y
eight nay okay so I think next we're on
to our motion for ought to pass as
amended
any further discussion on the main
motion representative Bon um yes um the
reason that I will not be voting in
favor of this bill is it presents a lot
of of issues that really aren't
addressed in it it basically allows um a
parent uh to decide where they want
their child to go to school in any
school within the district there's a lot
of planning that goes on every year here
with school districts and deciding
classroom
compositions um a lot of Staffing
concerns knowing in advance what
students you're going to be servicing in
terms of special education services uh
there is already a process in place for
parents to do this but to make the
assumption that the superintendent shall
Grant the request without taking into
consideration all of these other issues
I find to be problematic thank you
thank you represent of Woodcock cell
just a followup uh I also will not be
suppoed this but my reason a little bit
different it doesn't identify the number
of times a parent can apply or how many
times they can move during the year and
it doesn't identify the super the school
calendar and my concern is on Multi
school like elementary schools or lar
Community two middle schools when that
youngster moves the curriculum may not
be aligned at all and they could be way
behind or way ahead and then we lost
teacher time going to the new class
reorientation so I think I I think the
10day piece is is is by itself is
terrific the rest I I I can't support
thank you thank you representative
Cornell I also won't be supporting this
um and I do like the the tend day thing
but it still says the superintendent
does not find in the best interest of
the student um can request a hearing to
determine if the student is experience a
manifest educational hard hardship
that's already in law so we don't really
need to be doing this because they can
request it and this and this one again
says to determine if a student's
experience a manifest educational
hardship so I don't know that this is
even necessary so I will be voting
no thank
you uh seeing no further uh discussion U
mam clerk we're voting on ought to pass
as amended with Amendment 0103
H Vice chairman Noble yes representative
Terry yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
moris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell no representative
Murray no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no representative
bon no representative Damon no
Representative kuger no representative
Snodgrass no chairman cordelli yes ten
eight n okay will there be um a Minority
Report repres muray thank
you um and if we could get all the
reports in when Wednesday morning to to
me by Wednesday morning be be great so
we can get them in the calendar uh for
session next
[Music]
week
yes hton or email
um
uh email is um there's a
form electronically is easier so you can
copy and paste but um
if that's that doesn't work for you then
paper's okay
yeah uh next we'll take up
not1 no okay
229 house bills
329 relative to school district policies
governing air quality and temperature
issues in
schools and um representative Terry I
believe you have a motion yes Mr
chairman uh I move uh in expedient to
legislate okay is there a second second
second represent
NATO uh would you like to speak to your
motion sure um we heard uh extensive uh
testimony given uh on this uh on this
bill um and uh what we heard was was
rather interesting as we moved through
the testimony um both the uh
superintendent Association and the
school boards Association indicated that
they believed that this was unnecessary
and that um they were perfectly capable
of being able to handle this um as uh
School administrators and as local
school boards um we um certainly value
uh local control here with respect to um
our schools and we hear this uh
repeatedly um and I think um given the
fact that we have heard from the school
boards Association and the
superintendent Association that they
believe that they can provide a safe
environment uh for the students in their
schools this bill is really
unnecessary uh one uh one final note
here that with respect to the
Environmental Protection Agency tools um
uh once again this appears to be in a
front to local control because the word
encourage is removed and the word
require is being put in place um feel
that's unnecessary thank
you thank you repres NATO do you have
any further
comments okay thank you comments from
the
committee represent Woodcock thank you
chair
um this bill has been a long standing in
in uh the air quality piece and I made
the note and I actually thought I
written the Schoolboard Association
supported it but apparently I was wrong
um but that being said all this add all
this does is add the temperature uh when
they do the annual the
annual um inspection and the bill really
doesn't solve a lot because they do the
annual inspection typically in June and
July when nobody's in the building but
it does identify a need that teachers
identified that impacts academic
learning and that the heat in the
building so when we have 75 NAD 85 990
and September because we don't have a
condition in the buildings or the only
place that has it is the administrator's
office or the principal's office
everyone else is faltering we really
don't see a lot of learning going on and
most of the windows in the last 10 years
open an inch I mean there's not much air
going through either they put the fans
on it's just like another heating system
so always saying to the people add in
this bill when you do your policy to
figure out where the poor air is at
least check the temperature um where the
other options because we have case after
case after case of teachers and students
cting in classrooms all over this state
in August September October and when
days there's no learning going on
because they too hot that's all thank
you thank
you representative dry thank you um I
wanted to talk about lines 11 to 13
about emergency response planning and
heat ownness prevention um we've seen
three bills in the last year so when
with aeds one with um epipens and now
this one each one takes a little bit of
a first aid course and makes it into
required training for teachers that they
have to keep up it's not really taught
that way you don't retain certification
by doing little pieces of a first aid
course to do that we heard from
Schoolboard Association I believe that
said there's another training that has
to be done and kept up really I don't
see any way to keep the training going
that say certified except maybe you say
you've read something every year um and
I don't think you need a law to do that
I look through the Tools for Schools to
see if they had any probable programs
that we could do that they could say to
do it they have nothing they just in
they just talk about air quality they
don't talk about temperature at all so
there isn't really a program or a plan
that you could actually say yes we're
going to follow that we're going to
train our teachers this and we're going
to make sure that they stay trained with
that it doesn't exist represent Dam
thank you Mr chair um I'm in support of
this bill it's a policy bill it's for us
to be more thorough and diligent in
considering what the school environment
for both students and staff is and I
just want to officially say as a
co-sponsor there was no intent of
affront to anyone for what they're doing
or not doing please don't sign
that represent Woodcock thank you
represent in response represent Dr is
common I think she she illuminates a a a
marvelous point there is no plan and
that's the point there is no plan for
this to be taken care of and it's saying
to us we've had this problem for years
now we're saying make a plan we had the
I agree with you 100% Ro dry that there
is no plan as it stands now and the
schools hav been doing one nor have the
superintendent nor have the principal
particularly when it comes to
temperature and heat control except for
you know the nurses happen to be trained
so I think all this bill says is you
have to do a plan you haven't done it
for 20 years and now it's getting heater
hotter
thank
you thank you anything else from anyone
else on the
committee seen nothing um representative
dry Madam clerk are
you
ready motion is motion is
itl vice chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tzar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell no representative
Murray no representative Woodcock hello
representative Hall no representative
bon no
representative uh Damon no
Representative kuger no representative
Snodgrass no and chairman cordelli yes
that be 10 yays eight Nays I think we
should try and keep our responses to uh
yes or no
all um next
is um Mr
chair allow minority on that yes I'm
sorry for sure do it yes who's
who CL we'll be doing it okay
and next is House Bill
76 which is uh relative to tracking
special ed complaints and I'd like to
make a motion Mr chair that ought to
pass thank you uh is there a
second I'll second second by
representative
Noble uh discussion representative
Freeman thank you Mr chair um seeing as
we strive to increase transparency while
ensuring privacy in
fura um this is a common sense piece of
legislation um that will allow more
transparency and will not create a
burden on the Department of Education
seeing as they already collect this
information repr Noble nothing further
other comments from the
committee representative Boni
um if you look at the information that's
being requested all of this is already
currently available on the special
education website I'm looking at a link
that totally
analyzes all that is requested on uh the
page two um lines 4 through 7 um what is
included in this particular Bill are
things that um might impact student
privacy um which include uh being able
to detect who might be uh the student by
the name of the school district and I
cannot see any reason at all why we
would need the name of any law firm
representing the school district all of
those other um a through D is right here
on the website and I would think that
this could be just handled by putting a
link to the website thank you thank you
rson muray thank you I too um will be
voting no on this motion uh with regard
to the fact that um there is direct
contradiction with regarding
suppressions and um information in
smaller districts that could identify a
learner um unintentionally but because
of the types of services rendered um and
to the same point that um representative
Bon had mentioned I do believe that most
of this information is already available
on the Doe's
website thank you representative uh
Damon
thank you reiterating the concerns about
small towns I represent nine communities
seven of them are less than 1500
residents cuden where I live has 28
students in rc4 school
district if you identify the district
you are identifying the child that's not
right rent Woodcock be I just want to
add in we think of the commentary this
morning about the young woman who the
woman who is here and said that her
youngster had been in private school for
12 years if that came under this case
there's no question about you know what
school district she came from and she
would have been self-identified by this
bill there would been no privacy
there anything
further see nothing Madam clerk whenever
you're
ready yes motions s to pass Vice
chairman Noble yes representative Terry
yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell no representative
Murray no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no representative
bon no representative Damon no
Representative kuger no representative
Snodgrass no chairman cordelli yes 10 y
eight Nays
thank you very much everybody um I think
that that finishes is Minority
Report the what is there a Minority
Report yes um Minority Report on on that
Bill yes representative
Balon and I take it's the motion is itl
and voting again on it so do we just
assume um well I I I assume that if our
motion is off to pass your motion is itl
but you
know be glad to be corrected oh I I I
didn't
know sure you know I'll try and ask in
the future for
sure we don't need we don't need to go
yeah
right okay well thank you very much
everybody um we'll be back uh
on Wednesday and I think uh we have a
full day of hearings on
Wednesday
e e